and we are live yet again with another speed
chess championship match in this year of 2020.
alongside me grand master young ludwig hammer back
as he should be as magnus carlson returns for his
second match of the year hammer magnus returns
we've got vladislav artemyev online and blitz
i don't want to say specialist but a guy that i
think less known than magnus carlson could give
a fight today your thoughts quickly before we dive
into the format on what magnus needs to do to make
sure he he maintains and holds off let us love
our chimeyev um there's no easy match in chess
and magnus is coming straight off a finals loss in
the champions chess tour so artemyev i think needs
to pounce on the few times magnus is vulnerable
and and and and strike while the iron is hot first
of all that's a fantastic point you know before we
dive into more i want to i want to bring that up
because you said in our last commentary uh session
together with magnus playing is that magnus is
rarely put on tilt right so we know the guy's good
right he's the world champion he's the best in the
world but also he's so good that very often
you know he he can also win games on momentum
his opponents can be intimidated you rarely
see him put in a position where he's kind of
having to gather his emotions and in this
particular format of the scc with so many games
back to back you know what what would that do to
put magnus in that kind of position especially
as you highlighted he did just lose on his
birthday to wesley so right at the stealing open
uh yeah so i i think uh crucially you need to
try and win two games in a row against madness
uh because that will really put him in an
unfamiliar situation the problem of course
is that winning two games in a row against magnus
is incredibly difficult right and that's why he
doesn't have any experience dealing with with
that situation right okay yeah well said and
it's funny because maybe the last time we
experienced that before wesley defeating uh
magnus at the skilling open last week was was
maybe back in 2019 when wesley defeated magnus
at the fisher random world chess championship
so you're right it doesn't happen often will
it happen today or will magnus do what we expect
magnus to do often which is which is win his chess
match handily either way let's remind the fans
real quick what's coming up here this is the scc
we gotta we gotta make sure you know what you're
in store for in case you've missed it it's a 16
player single elimination knockout bracket 2020
speed chess championship is the same format we've
had for years it's a winning format 90 minutes
counting down of five minutes 60 minutes of
three minute followed by 30 minutes of bullet
of course the one second increment throughout
make sure that the chess x's and o's always matter
just as much if not more than what's on the clock
if a match is tied hammer we will head to overtime
we've had one match go to overtime uh this year
for ruja fedo say which the fans who've been here
early you just had the pleasure of seeing in our
highlight clips of the month you can check out
that video on youtube hammer we've also got double
the prizes here in round two so it's 3k to the
winner and then 3k split on win percentage your
your thoughts real quick on why more events don't
do prizes distributed based on win percentage
um didn't expect i don't really know it's a
really good question i was actually trying to
do some calculations whether or not a tournament
like norway chess um can can can try to award
uh wins monetarily and how that would look
as a structure um and i i think it's uh
the concept is great and then you need to figure
out how to execute it right and well i think you
guys have some experience with that right yeah
it's in we talk about it a lot and of course
it you know i'm the guy who's been doing
chess.com shows since since they started so
i guess no way it doesn't sound biased coming out
of my mouth but you know i've talked about this
just as friends and chess professionals off camera
and i you know we're always talking about ways to
make sure chess maintains its fighting spirit
even down the stretch right we've talked about
ways that you know they do scoring uh different we
know uh norway chess has tried that and and find
ways to reward you know points with black and with
white and make sure that chess is fighting and and
we always look at this as an opportunity to make
sure that even if a match is a runaway there's
still something to fight for and now within
maybe the several hundreds of dollars for each
individual game so anyway fun stuff and either
way several hundred dollars is also on the line
this week with multiple scc matches for guests to
move if you want to play head over to chess.com
click on that button below the chess tv player
you'll be taken directly to live chest to follow
the games or one of our very helpful and awesome
moderators and staff can share a link with you
on youtube and twitch leaving those boring
platforms behind you know what you can't do
on twitch and youtube play chess that's dumb go to
chess.com and play chess anyway the bracket hammer
so has moved on to the semifinals maxine bache the
grave has moved on to the semifinals we've got two
matchups coming up and honestly i just want to
move right into our predictions here because it's
it's not quite what we had magnus carlsen as the
favorite over mock sudo the last time we were here
but still pretty heavily in magnus's favor right
i mean whenever magnus plays chess he's gonna be
the favorite uh and muksudulu i wanna give credit
to him that he got a lot of good positions he had
a lot of uh good opportunities he just let
them slip when both players were down to
25 20 seconds each uh artemyev if he wants to get
a good showing he needs to do what magsudu did
but he also needs to strike in those time critical
situations and uh being low on time the lower time
the more randomness the easier it is to make a
blunder you want to put yourself in that situation
where the game is competitive with uh 20 seconds
remaining and maksudulu did that but then failed
in the critical situations um artemyev needs to
do the same and then succeed uh as the the time
becomes stressful very well said and obviously
maybe not everyone here who's uh who's here early
remembers the monsoon mesh closely but uh but
you and i do and and i think you make a great
point there it's easy to look at the scoreboard
right hammer when it's over and say oh magnus
won by a lot but actually a lot of those games
as it is with super grand masters we're still
very close down the stretch so will vladislav
artemyev succeed where mog sulu failed and as
you said maybe the recipe to upsetting uh you know
a goliath like magnus carlsen is not just once but
twice in a row right put him in a position where
you're you're building momentum see if he can
recover from the the tilt factor that is in the
scc that so many people have experienced um and
and then hope for the best right well we have
about 60 seconds before the game starts so give a
quick shout out the chess tv the twitch to youtube
we still got actually got a lot of you here pretty
early just because magnus is playing this morning
a little bit of a different time zone than we've
normally done these sccs and the first time we've
had a back to back in a uh in a in a very what a
day it's gonna be what a day right what a day it's
gonna be um i joked i woke up early this morning
it was like hey this is tiring and then i was like
what am i talking about i get to go commentate
with magnus and ikaro and hammer this is gonna be
an awesome day and i can't wait um and uh and yeah
i think games will be beginning in just seconds
here it's time it's time to begin let's do this
thing what do you think you ready um i'm ready uh
and i hope the players are ready as well because
here it's gonna be important to uh to get a good
start and and take take advantage of the white
pieces whomever is so lucky to benefit from those
well by the way um before the game starts we just
had a subscriber which reminds me i get to give an
early shout out to all those who are here to throw
us your throw us your prime hence the reason
we named him primetime smackdown right subtle
suggestive marketing there because guess who
plays during our primetime smackdown today hammer
uh or are you going to show our prime
time smackdown daniel that's right
the one where i crushed looking forward to it
destroyed you that one no spoilers danny no
spoilers okay uh it's gonna be awesome i can't
wait so if you are not a subscriber to twitch
um we do we do appreciate it we know that
uh we obviously run ads it's no secret here
this content we bring you a lot goes into our
events here at chess.com and we appreciate you
you uh putting up with that as we as we try
to bring you the best content and chef shows
uh online in the world as best we can anyway
and if you do want to avoid ads please consider
throwing us a subscription you can also watch
on chess.comtv for an ad free experience um and
uh we do appreciate your premium membership over
there as well so um anyway thank you so much for
everyone who's already here and uh please consider
consider watching me and hammer at the primetime
smackdown let's just say that no matter what
happens between us i always have fond memories
uh thank you danny um okay um we are going to
say something funny no that wasn't funny enough
hamster 0730 just no i don't like that
guy i i was going to try and say something
funny but i failed in the moment and i
tried to relay the word to you instead
your trash talk has been wittier than i
expected um at times i'm not gonna lie um so
don't be gentle today be gentle you know i i've
i've been i've been coached by the best hey
it's not you i'm not i was waiting
for the punch line there you go
okay no i think botas is a fantastic trash
talker oh my god don't even i i don't even know
um anyway well we're waiting for the games to
begin thank you seriously the uh the subscribers
coming in we do appreciate it it's gonna be a
great day and uh no more ads as you subscribe
um i think the players are ready but obviously
there's something going on and just so everyone
knows the players are discussing with our team
there's a lot of staff that goes into making
these things possible and both players are also
on double camera which means fair play review
so they have a field of vision camera a
front-facing camera and then also on screen share
um and so really doing everything we can
to make sure that uh that both the players
feel secure that their opponents are are
properly observed and proctored and the um
and the audience can know that even though these
days there are all kinds of earpieces and things
people do and everyone knows that chess.com
algorithm for cheat detection is mostly based on
dna evidence of the game right data that kind of
removes the question of what people might be doing
just want you to know we're doing that hammer
have you ever played a tournament where you had
multiple cameras on you a chess tournament
by the way not that other kind of tournament
uh i the only place would be somewhere like
norway chess which was tv broadcasted oh okay but
other than that no okay well we'll go to
full we'll go to the larger camp for us
as the players get set they're working out
some technical difficulties at the moment
um players are allowed to listen to music
but not through headphones which again
confirms all different sound waves they might be
hearing always possible someone's watching this
show they see a brilliant suggestion by danny
wrench and then someone tells them in the ear
magnus danny just said to play this move play
it that's that's a real life scenario i like how
you could have used me as an example but chose
to go with yourself i'm just being realistic
buddy just be your confidence is incredible um
everyone should aspire to have your confidence
i you know i appreciate that um you know
the other thing people can aspire to do is
play in tomorrow's bot battles hammer we know that
you're you're super busy um for those who don't
know you are literally the face of tv2 and in
some ways just commentary in norway i would argue
um but uh you're also an aspiring chess streamer
you have a you have a twitch channel maybe one
of our mods can uh can throw a thorough command
in there for people to go give hammer a follow
i don't know if you'll be streaming tomorrow
but the bot battles are gonna be a ton of fun
i'm pretty sure everybody is playing all
the cool kids are playing i'm going to play
meaning i'm not even going to do commentary i'm
going to play and try to win some of the bounty
prizes i'm certainly going to beat the living
tar out of young beth harmon i'll tell you that
that sounded weird so who's this guy
on the left what who's this guy on the
left is it i know it looks like a uh a
young and somehow creepier john travolta
if that's even is that who you compare yourself
to john travolta no it just it looks like a creepy
john travolta you know all the movies he has
slicked back terror it's not a compliment it's
it's it's awkward i i gotta talk to uh to dallyn
um our our head designer be like man i would have
rather looked like jimmy neutron than that yeah
i think in these within these four there's three
very good representations of the people and
then there's just this plain old white guy
um i i got feedback that i wasn't funny enough
last time and i've really you are first of all
anybody who says that is wrong i actually think
we have a great a great rapport and um i'm i'm
uh honored to be your wingman whenever we
have the opportunity so and uh i thought i
was your wingman no dude i'm your wingman i'm the
wingman of anyone we bring on here okay um but uh
oh okay so we're having we're having uh we're
working out some technical stuff right now
with with the zoom screen share and those sorts of
things so um everyone just uh just hold tight hold
tight don't don't be frustrated um why don't we
bring back are you talking to yourself right now
yeah talking to myself sometimes i do that on
air in front of also do it at home in front of
my kids i also do it alone in the shower
i do i talk about myself a lot to myself
um so let's get more specific right we were
we were moving through the preview content
a little faster anticipating a start time
but as we work out the tech difficulties
um we said that artemiev needs to win a couple
games in a row to put magnus in that in that
potentially tiltable position as you look at
the time control and our predictions hammer
where do you where do you feel i mean we always
say the underdog needs to strike early right i
tend to agree with that um but where do you feel
uh artemyev needs to get his points um other
than his six and a half to three score on the
five-minute portion which actually doesn't make
any sense i don't know i'll talk to you it doesn't
but don't be frustrated danny don't don't don't be
frustrated okay it's all gonna be okay okay anyway
so where do you feel with your you know self-talk
where do you think artemium needs to score
um all categories um yeah well the thing is
uh in this format uh the one minute section has
a tendency to just pile on with a lot of games
in a very short time frame and and that means if
you start losing two games in a row in the one
minute section then you're just done for but what
i have noticed previously in this format is that
matches need to be competitive get going into
the one minute in order for there to be any drama
very often there's one player who has shown
their superiority in the blitz sections and by
the time we get to the bullet section to the one
minute section then it's just one guy who's been
crushed and whose confidence has been eviscerated
um and then he stands no chance to uh to mount a
comeback so i think number one artemium needs to
make sure that there's not more than three points
separating them going into the one minute section
and then uh he needs to kind of even if he's down
on points uh he needs to make sure he still
has the the inner strength the confidence
that uh he feels he can strike back uh in the
in the bullet section well said and well timed
because right as you finish that point we do
have liftoff everybody we appreciate you uh
sitting through that um and again just so you know
uh what was going on was screen share difficulties
but uh regardless of the match and who we have
who we have playing we want to make sure that
there are no screen share difficulties and that
everyone is uh being observed in the same way so
we didn't want to start early to make before all
security measures were uh were taken and uh we
have magnus carlsen playing the modern variation
if you know your move orders in the caro con and
queen to c7 that's a that's not an everyday move
there from our champion big surprise from artemyev
and i like his opening choice he's using the karo
khan against magnus who used the korokan against
wesley's soul just last week and lost with it
using the black pieces artemiev is essentially
uh bringing up some bad memories here from
bringing lots of bad memories for magnus magnus
took some took a minute there before he played
bishop d3 um but uh but now we're headed toward
what is sort of a typical kind of call it
classical french structure with the with
the exchange of the d for the e pawn but with
this these on c6 and queen on c7 thrown in what
what what does that do to change the dynamic
does black have an early e5 in his future
i don't know it looks kind of strange from
artemyev but at least he got magnus to spend some
time in the opening this is very reminiscent of
uh games i've seen with uh the big anatoly karpov
the the master of the carbocon opening uh and um
it's so solid it's very difficult to break down
and and magnus is going to have a tough time with
it today okay interesting and he is also down on
the clock which maybe not exactly what we uh what
we expected for the start of the match um well you
know well magnus is a slow starter that's true
remember he mouse slipped in game one last time
and and in his match against uh magsodulu the
score was two to two when magnus won 10 games in a
row and managing to win 10 in a row is incredible
but it goes to show that we thought maxoudaly was
doing a great job initially and then he just got
crushed right so you can never rest easy playing
against magnus right now great point although
you also made the point as i was asking you to
break down the time controls that regardless
of the score artemia needs to keep the inner
confidence he needs to keep the inner focus right
and i will say that one thing i've observed about
vladislav one of the most consistent performers i
think outside of hikaru nakamura in our speeches
grand prix this year uh hammer is he is kind of
that he's got that emotionless killer kind of
mindset you know he doesn't doesn't seem to
get rattled every time i would say you know
oh that's a huge blunder you think he's going to
lose his focus he does have that which i think is
kind of uh something that a lot of the top players
have right where they sort of have a short memory
about mistakes right and so we'll see if
he can he can maintain himself um even if
the score gets a little bit rough there um yeah
but one of the most exciting things about these
internet chess tournaments is that the two best
players magnus and hikaru are also the two players
most prone to showing their emotions on camera
really visibly being upset or happy and so on and
so forth and i i think this has been one of the
greatest things of internet chess right that the
players because they feel like they're alone in
their homes uh they're not hiding their emotions
over the board they would always quell any sort
of sign the opponent could use whereas here
uh they they show more emotion and frankly that's
fantastic and i love that magnus and ikaru the
two best players are the most visible in in in
relaying uh what's going on in their head again
well said we've talked about that a lot with
the scc and then other events like the pro
chess league and other things that there's been
in some ways a more intimate connection fans
have felt online with players because of exactly
what you said you get you get this sort of view
of and the immediate reaction because players
are so comfortable right you know when you're
not wearing pants it's easier to let your guard
down you know just are you wearing pants danny
that may or may or may not it's business up
top party down low the chest commentators world
and look at this from magnus magnus had the
opportunity to castle but he was scared that
the kings would be on opposite sides of the board
allowing artemyev to start an attack and so magnus
by bringing his bishop out he's signaling
that he's kind of scared and that he wants
to put his king on the same side as artemis king
because that's known as being a safer positioning
100 and i wonder if it changes the end game
slightly right so when we look at the long term
nature of the four on three but then the three
on two on this side but black's king is already
on that side of the board that typically is a good
spot if you get to an end game and you're dealing
with someone trying to convert a passer so that's
i mean a lot of things about this position to me
are just not clear yet right there's there's and
that's probably why the engine also feels it's a
very very close to level position but then i look
at the clock after that whole kind of tangent and
say artemia doing well with black right he's
uh yeah i was gonna say uh a big uh one minute
advantage on the clock for the russian and here
he goes striking out against white's queen as well
very aggressive play from him magnus is going
to be trying to show that uh in in the words
of our coach seaman augustine magnus will try
to show that bishops are best in the long games
that they stay alive for a long time uh get
into an end game where there are fewer pawns
and bishops are best the fewer the pawns on
the board because both your own pawns and uh
your opponent's pawns have a tendency
of getting in the way of bishops
and and so that's why they're good uh in
the long run as the pawns get exchanged off
so we have uh siemen augustine to thank for your
great series on chess.com on the bishop pair and
you're in magnus's brilliant play i already knew
that but i'm pretending pretending i didn't anyway
no great point in all this highlight again the
bishop here is sort of white's long-term trump
card here because of the the fact that black
doesn't have a light square bishop so right
now it's not you know not not necessarily an issue
but that's what magnus is hoping for in the long
run okay we're starting to get spicy here hammer
knight b6 opens the rook will will our chimney of
risk going for this pawn i highly doubt that yeah
he says no no thank you i'll make the king safe
and magnus still down one minute on the clock and
he's about to be under one minute in total which
is a huge time advantage for artemyev and he's
going to be looking to keep pieces on the board
to keep the situation difficult and and try to
get magnus in with a bad decision in time trouble
bishop to c1 to renew defense on the night
um i think hammer highlighted the biggest the
biggest point here which is time but i still like
magnus's position in the long run regardless of
what the computer says i feel like the bishop
pair will have the potential to strike um
what is what is black i agree yeah i agree there's
nothing wrong with magnus's position it's just
the time is precarious and i think the biggest
mistake artemia can do make now is is just sit
there and run his clock trying to find the best
move sometimes you need to be a little cynical
and say well i'm not going to play perfect chess
but it doesn't matter because by playing quickly
i can put a lot of pressure on my opponent who's
maybe not very used to being in a situation where
he's low on time and and prone to making mistakes
so i think artemyev spending a half a minute on
one move there was um unnecessary no well said and
now now he goes for this plan a bishop d6 trying
to trying to take advantage of the queen being in
a precarious spot it's actually kind of awkward
yeah magnus's queen has been kicked around a
lot this game and it's clear that he's settling
into the match because he's still spending so much
time while the p sacrifice from magnus giving away
a piece for two pawns he's about to get a third
pawn on g4 but in general a piece is very valuable
and artemia also doing a good job of getting rid
of magnus's bishop pair he has the upper hand both
on the board and on the clock it's it's super
interesting magnus went for that i guess from
a practical point of view he was feeling both
the pressure of his queen and the fact that he's
getting low on the clock but yeah i i like that
artillery if not that he took the piece hammer but
that he did so very quickly he's like all right
here we go i'm not going to overthink this let's
go keep magnus under time pressure um i think but
with three pawns for the for the for the bishop uh
i think it's very important that artemyev keep
hold on to his pawn on age six uh because if
magnus is able to eliminate all the pawns on one
side of the board his defensive task on the other
side becomes much easier so that might may explain
why artemiev chose to use the rook that was in the
center of the board and used that one to push over
to the side because he wants to keep his corner
rook protecting that very important remaining pawn
a great point what do you think about magnus's
queen trade there right he's relying on the end
game where in some ways the knights are not always
the best pieces coordinating against maybe ideas
where the you know you start doing things on the
king side here it's interesting yeah i don't think
magnus has given up hope on winning this game
right um and now he also equalized on time we're
gonna get one of those dramatic 20 seconds each
situations and this could go either way
i'm surprised how positive the computer is
for black precisely for the reason you mentioned
that the knights are difficult to coordinate but
here come the knights artemia maneuvering them
over to the center pushing around magnus's bishop
uh ma artemia in a good situation but both players
so low on time it's anyone's game 100 agree and
yeah the coordination you'd like it but again
the more i look at it i feel like white's doing
maybe better than the computer says too but okay
this is it's gonna be a photo finish regardless
yeah and look at how artemia is putting the
pressure down on that white pawn artemyev gets the
pawn captured magnus is relying on getting that
last pawn on the other side but artemia with his
rook is trying his best to prevent it but he fails
magnus gets the pawn on the age file which means
magnus now only has to concentrate on defending
uh the left-hand side of the board and yeah i
i think he has decent chances to you know get out
of time with the drug tim did get the second rank
right which gets you worried about future mating
nets even with the rook and knight a little bit
right a little bit uh and magnus also down to less
than 10 seconds as is our tamiya it's gonna be one
heck of a finish but there magnus blunders his
pawn on the side uh artemia doesn't pick it up
pawn is alive but the other side of the board
is not alive artemia with a great job there uh
getting magnus on the side where he thought he
was comfortable and artemyev is gonna take the
win in this uh first game uh showing everyone that
he is not going down without a fight yeah and by
the way wins with black right um i mean assuming
he converts here um he will convert this i have
no doubt yeah i don't know that the psac was was
really dubious by magnus i mean from a practical
perspective i think it was super interesting it's
just that artemiev played quickly handled it well
and uh and ultimately an extra piece proved
better in the time scramble again our champion
look at the technique protects the knight now the
rook will come back to f2 and uh and magnus just
throws in the towel so wow right we have liftoff
everybody if you if you showed up this morning
early on the west coast or mid-afternoon over
there somewhere in europe thinking all right
time for another magnus steamroll as as robner
and i predicted yesterday i don't think either
one of these back-to-back matches are going to
be easy for the favorites magnus or hikaru so
stick around and that that first game proves it
hammer you said artemium needs to win two in a
row to put magnus in in a position now he has
the white pieces and a chance to do it early
yeah and if he succeeds what a success for him
but on the other hand magnus is infamous for
striking back with a win after a loss and here he
goes again being aggressive with the pawn on the
side of the board um i i think magnus is slightly
worse with the black pieces uh but winning this
for artemyev and really unsettling magnus is is
gonna be uh really difficult and magnus can live
with being uh one game down because there's
three hours to left right that's true but all
right our team of doing early what what mag zulu
failed to do for for a very long time in in their
first matchup which was get a w make sure magnus
knows uh this is not gonna be a walk in the park
we got 10 000 of you on twitch 4 000 plus
of you on youtube and the day has just begun
appreciate all the love we've been getting lots of
subscribers lots of chat rolling on chess tv too
and uh and thank you for being here um all right
uh james coleman says black gonna win this right
because or maybe that was from the previous game
i don't know but uh all right what is what does
magnus need to do here hammer what's the plan in
this kind of obscure looking weird ready g3 stuff
look at magnus's pawns danny do you see anything
they have in common uh well a lot of them are
on light squares if i'm looking at the queen
side i also see a natural idea of going for e5
um well i have the suspicion that magnus is going
to place every single pawn on a light square which
doesn't really work well together with a light
squared bishop so magnus coming forward with
his knight in the center he's going to be hope
that artemyev captures the knight in the center
so that magnus can take back with his bishop and
i think it's likely we'll see magnus giving up
the knight squared bishop for a night essentially
saying uh that um that the bishop uh can get a um
can't really do anything uh so it's better to
get it exchanged off uh given how many pawns
are still on the board yeah and he does so uh
quick uh quick trigger happy board resize for
those who are gonna clip that and make fun of me
later we'll work on that little mouse sensitivity
anyway um all right he gets the bishop in so i was
gonna highlight if you said he's gonna put all his
pawns on light squares then the idea of getting
the bishop outside the pawn chain makes a lot
of positional sense but here comes artemia forcing
the issue on the queen side right he wants tension
to break wants things like a capture to open up
the a file here um again again i kind of like
how our timmy is playing yeah mainly he's looking
at magnus's pawn on b7 and that's the the guy you
always want to get after uh when your opponent
uh lets the bishop out of its cage um right and
i'm not sure how magnus should defend that
guy it's a difficult thing because probably
he wants to use his queen but if he moves his
queen to d7 he's got to count on what happens
if if white moves the knight up uh in the center
uh if the queen goes to c8 or c7 he's putting the
queen on the same file as white's rook which
is not a good thing to have happen to the
so magnus right now struggling to find out
how to defend the pawn wait i'm surprised
yeah i'm surprised by that decision from magnus
because now now we have an opening on on the on
the far side and it feels to me like white is
better prepared uh to get something out of that
well you said it too the queen can't guard the
b-pawn at least not safely on the c file um
queen d7 does it but are we worried about ideas
with the knight coming in are we no i don't think
so i think uh we're happy to give up our bishop
for that night should it get into the center
but magnus was not happy with that but his
decisions have cost so much time magnus once
again down on time over a minute and he puts his
queen on that same file as white's rook which is
something you mostly want to avoid and here we
see artemyev trying to take advantage of uh the
opening on on the side rank trying to get the work
involved uh all the way down on the other side
are we going to see knight a6 or knight d7 right
it feels like rook a8 is too powerful a threat
for a magnus oh wait a second holy begins
not see that one coming yep that's a pin
i like it yeah what what tension between the pawns
all four pawns looking at each other and frankly
none of them wants to capture uh but you're gonna
have to uh it's uh live or die for those pawns
over the next couple of moves yeah i wonder if
magnus has a way to force white um let's bring
up the analysis board and just quickly show the
the obvious right the whole point is hammer said
you can't take here because of that oh well hammer
magnus does capture c4 but the risk i thought was
but if queen takes maybe maybe magnus will take
twice actually right trying to strap an end game
where maybe white ends up with an isolated pawn
as a weakness on d4 as is maybe in the future
yeah so uh vladislav takes with the pawn
instead trying to build good central control
with his pawns now magnus he's going to try to
claim that those pawns are vulnerable but on the
other hand taking with the pawn has now allowed
for the the white queen to give protection to the
fianchetto bishop which is very good for white
because that means you can continue pushing
forward in the middle if it was artemium's move
right now he would play d5 and magnus is down
two minutes on the clock which means he is not
at all comfortable with what is going on here
yeah and and if you just tuned in this was a
similar story from game one uh magnus was was
way down on the clock ultimately it did come
down to a very equal time scramble but still
it shows that our champion is capable out of
the first stage of things of making magnus
uncomfortable um big moment now artemium has 95
big tactics going on and magnus shaking his head
magnus sees what's going on we have to do that
on the analysis so the idea everyone is if 95
bishop takes takes e4 you can't take because
the rook hangs so 95 is a monster move black
would have to take on b5 first and then what
happens here right hammer it's a total mess
yeah i don't really know but black's
knight did not like this situation however
a different move was played by artemyev instead he
he chose to get his work involved immediately and
magnus just moving that rook into a defensive
position but maybe that's what the position
required well maybe magnus was actually shaking
his head kind of to his own time management like
i i had that thought when he first did it it
wasn't about queen c6 and he is he is still equal
but but only 20 seconds is like hey there's a lot
of chess to be played here man you got to speed up
yeah and magnus going into an end game basically
just trying to defend um but on the other hand
magnus and end games it's like norwegians and
brown cheese it just goes together what i mean
appropriate would have been salmon norwegians
and salmon brown cheese it's good i promise it's
well you learn something new every day
here on chess tv at least at least you
can go home and say that um what you need
to know danny is that we sell the salmon
you know ah you you you i think norway
is is all about salmon but we sell it
we let other people i was there last year and
just about every buffet i went to you know
scandinavians and how much they love their buffets
every single buffet breakfast lunch and dinner
had salmon okay back to the game okay magnus is
unwinding with b6 hammer knight d6 coming next
and uh something tells me like you said magnus
and and end games norwegians and brown cheese i
think magnus is gonna do okay down the stretch
here yeah even with just 20 seconds remaining
magnus is the one going for the win in an end
game and that's because white has two pawns
that are disconnected from the rest of the army
these two pawns are unable uh to be defended by
other pawns meaning they need pieces in defensive
positions and as magnus now is coming with his
knight uh to attack the the furthest forward of
these pawns um artemium is gonna have to get his
rook in a defensive position which is terrible
it's just suffering and he knows it because his
time advantage has gone from 2 minutes to 30
seconds artemium has completely blown this game
and he knows it the trend now in magnus's favor
magnus down on the score uh magnus definitely
going to go for the win here uh even though he
was in a a precarious time situation earlier
agreed with everything you said i like the
technique there too he's not worried about
the b6 plane i think because why is he not
worried about that pawn i think he has nice c8
okay but then 20 seconds left hammer this knight
this knight might might actually fall prey to some
tempe and this this king is activating itself very
quickly up the board i'm i don't know i i don't
want to jinx things early but i feel like we might
have a tied match after this given how magnus is
so so accurate in these types of end
games our tamiya should probably go like
age four and king f3 get that king involved
towards the middle right but he's spending
so much time now and he had that big two-minute
time advantage which has completely disappeared
and that is just not good time management he
played bad moves and took his time making them
and now magnus by rook c8 and artemyev shakes
his head pins the knight knight to see set okay
no reason to play knight c7 it would just be a
trade everybody but this heads-up retreat of the
rook is just paralyzing for artemyev yeah
magnus is just going to push his pawn and
that is going to distract white's rook from the
defense of the white knight and our tamiya loses
despite having a good position despite being
two minutes up on the clock magnus strikes back
and let's go to the announcement show to just show
that that final moment hammer because it's kind
of fascinating when a position is equal besides a
pawn on material hammer but look at the eval plus
seven for black like if you look at the paralyzed
nature of this everyone i just want to point out
how unique it is the rook cuts off the king and
so there's literally nothing this king can do
about baby girl brittany joining the party on
b1 the only thing that white will eventually do
is have to move i mean you sit and eventually
the rook goes well i can't do this anymore i
come back which just loses the knight so
literally everything in the position is
frozen because of this sort of uh brilliant and
played very quickly move rook c8 and the game was
over the moment it came on the board with rook
a8 rook c8 so anyway very very nice technique
we are now level as hammer says we joined we
joined game three and well we've already got
already got some trickiness with e5
let me just show the opening real quick
it was another carol khan this time a
classical variation e5 a pawn sack that
is regained quickly with a common tactic between
85 check we'll pick up the pawn here everybody so
your thoughts here hammer this is uh tibiakov's
pet line with the white pieces and tibi is one
of the players known to be incredibly difficult
to beat his wide openings are so solid but magnus
uh he's going for this because he appreciates
the bishop pair so magnus with two bishops are
temiev with just one magnus is going to hope for
a long game where his uh bishops can reign supreme
our boy our boy seaman angelstein strikes again
right his influence on you guys and the bishop
here i'm to go into twitch chat and use one
of my emotes my boy magnus i'll let you do it
well you'll do that i'll remind everybody thank
you for all the subs coming in and all the all
the chat we're getting every room is lively and
poppin youtube twitch chess tv it's gonna be a
fun day the match is level we've got a bishop pair
here and a carrot con for the second time when our
timmy was black if you're just tuning in this
was also game one where vladislav won with the
second move so we'll see if this carro con is a is
a consistent feature here by the way we had almost
a thousand observers directly in chess.com and a
couple hundred people playing guess the move so
a lot of people playing guess the move head over
to chess.com if our mods can share a link there
and to play against the move to win cash prizes
try to play like magnus all right go ahead hammer
i'm no longer a fan of magnus's bishops or to
say i'm a fan of the bishops but i'm not a fan of
the knight on g3 and artemyev has just played an
excellent move restricting this knight's movement
uh taking away that central square in the middle
um and magnus when he's moving his bishop now
he's exposing his bishop oh i thought bishop f3
was played no no sorry that was a mouse slipped by
me on the board sometimes i get a little trigger
happy i get so excited yeah because i was gonna
say moving the bishop is definitely something
magnus is considering because then the knight
can move where the bishop was right uh it's
just that moving the bishop will allow for
artemyev to move both his knights into uh central
locations and that's not going to be a fun time
for magnus so i'm going to say the kurokon
will not be featured a lot in this match
because magnus has gotten a beating with the white
pieces he's going to have to change his first move
that's i mean that would be something
right if our champions carol khan
makes magnus change as early as game five
which will be the next time the norwegian
has the white pieces okay he finds bishop g5 i
i like that move because one of the things about
the knight coming to the center is the rook will
reinforce protection here this kind of makes the
rook go to an awkward square and i had a tactic
idea bishop c4 hammer because i'm just the only
potential problem with these pawns is the light
squares right which is the bishop artemia lacks
doesn't have to move and artemia with
his bishop intercepting uh he's gotten
rid of magnus's bishop pair yep classic and magnus
yeah and magnus is still stuck with that knight
uh um on the edge of the board not really doing
much but here he goes for the idea i was talking
about and you know i agree with everything you're
saying maybe there's some tempe idea magnus can
bring the bishop in bring a rook over but then h2
is weak no you're right i mean this is super super
awkward for black to the point where maybe magnus
just needs to back up the bishop and be defensive
and what a move from artemyev there taking
with the king who would do that and who
would do that at such a pace he realizes that
the rook is no better in the middle uh it's
actually doing just fine where it is pointing
towards magnus's pawn on the side of the board
what a move from artemyev and magnus once again
shaking his head magnus has been in trouble
in three games in a row now and for the third time
in a row magnus is more than a minute down on the
clock uh he made a good escape in game two and
even came back to win it but it's very clear to
me that artemium has been the top player in
this match so far he just needs to you know
play better in the crunch moments such as that uh
second game no i mean you're right again for those
just tuning in our champion was was much better
as white even though he lost that second game for
magnus to tie it um i like this move h3 right
you're just fixing the fundamental problem
you'd like to play a move like rook d1 even
bishop f1 if you have to guard g2 to knighto4
magnus is going to slowly kind of unwind um
the position so i like this idea look at that
hammer he's coming to f6 very solidly placed in
the center yeah and seeing as how magnus now um
fix the problem on the edge i thought artemyev
was going to bring now his rook into the center
instead he's trying to exploit the fact that
he has that rook on the side of the board
putting pressure on magnus's rook
pawn but in those trades that happened
uh magnus was able to get his bad knight
into a good situation in the center
i was highlighting that as soon as f4 was
played and my face said at all i was like huh
what's interesting is as ugly as that transition
looks for these ducklings here on f3 and f2
black has the same problem uh so so the position
has become very level um considering artemia's
previous pressure uh i don't know that a draw
is a bad result for him anyway he's still
been doing very well with the black pieces but um
something maybe slipped there for for for artemia
and we've seen that in end games magnus can
be terrifying even when he's massively down
on the clock and now he's using his his knight to
terrorize black's king going after that pawn on g7
but on the other hand our temiev also has a pawn
in his sights on f3 so um it might just peter
out here uh with i wonder if magnus will play a
move like night g5 hammer to kick the rook and
maybe open up ideas that the rook gets involved
obviously it's maybe no better than just a trade
of g7 for f3 but timmy has got to think about
that because i'm wondering about this little
like yeah i like it because my i had this idea in
mind if rook h2 you're not actually threatening
to take because of this maybe there's you know
look at magnus yeah he's doing doing his thing
but it was an unfortunate spot for black's
king uh because magnus had the opportunity
and he didn't take it to play rook
e6 with an attack on black's king
and an attack on black's pawn and i'm
very surprised magnus didn't go for that
because that's just that's a pawn and not
only is it capturing a pawn it's also putting
pressure on the second black pawn i'm surprised
magnus didn't go for that instead yeah that too
uh honestly that's that's like just a blunder by
magnus because i'm realizing artemia has to go
back to the seventh rank and allow the two pawns
with check everyone because if king c5 you take
you're not even threatening to take that shake
and bake on e4 so this is a this is a uh i think
your right hammer i think not playing rookie six
was just straight up a blunder by magnus although
looks like he was kind of happy with this
technical transition he's like well now i'm in a
position with a better knight i've got pressure
on the pawns but for sure he missed rookie six
and once again we see magnus being way down
on time but as we enter the end game uh a face
without queens on the board magnus just reigns
supreme and artemyev can be very happy with his
openings but he needs to start playing these
end games better uh because uh magnus is uh
is gaining traction even though he's he's been
so far down on time for three games in a row yeah
i i agree although like you said end games and
brown cheese right the magnus loves them both um
so gonna be hard for our jimmy maybe to compete
in the most technical aspect of the game which
i think it's funny people at i think beginner
levels forget that that the end game is really
you know in many ways the hardest most accurately
most demanding phase and that's one of the reasons
magnus shines so well in it um i think our
teammate is defending i do believe magnus is
gonna regret having not played rookie six because
i feel like now that this setup is established
this knight so well kind of defending everything
he'll probably just go back to c8 here
i don't think artemis loses this oh look
at is that is that vlad saying hey maybe
maybe maybe i'll play this on a little bit yeah
wow uh a spell of confidence there from artemyev
and now with this check he's forcing magnus's king
back after which uh artemyev will capture a pawn
with a check it's a pawn up for artemyev and
it's a great display from him showing that
he's not afraid of magnus magnus was inviting this
back and forth back and forth going for the draw
seeing as how he was down on time but artemyev
has understood that he needs to use his time
advantage more and he took this opportunity to
to put some pressure on on magnus ooh but now
we're still getting it back and forth so magnus
obviously a great defender but it's a a promising
sign from artemyev that that he was willing uh to
go for the win there and put pressure on magnus
because if you're gonna play a three-hour
match against the best player in the world
you're gonna lose if you don't put pressure on him
you need to put him in those uh tricky situations
and that whenever magnus is down to 20 seconds
that's a tricky situation and artemia tried to
uh capitalize on it it didn't work this time but
maybe next time uh he he may reap the rewards
but let's let's bring up the analysis board and
just show that point because it's going to be a
storyline throughout the day you're 100 right that
right here when there was an opportunity for a
potential repeating of moves everyone the second
time it came our timing said you know what i'll
play king b6 and now you're in a bit of a tricky
situation with rook four not just the ideas i said
of advancing but f3 falling so it ultimately
did end in a draw but it's hammer's point is
that you can't play passive and and be happy for
a draw against magnus he makes magnus accept the
perpetual here rather than the other way around
so again just a good psychological point there
made from hammer we'll see if that continues to
be something that our tim is uh is able to go so
all right let's uh another game another game for
vladislav with the white pieces but we do remember
that he the only game he's lost so far was with
white so the the lower the time controls as
and in blitz chess specifically uh colors don't
really matter as much as in classical games
because there's uh more stuff happening
and and more um accidents prone to happen
which um which can happen both with white and
with black as we say in blitz bleep happens
right accidents happen when it comes to blitz um
now g4 is a is a move that says i'm not going to
have this hedgehog just continue to be one where
black and maneuver and this structure everybody
let's bring up the analysis board real quick
to highlight that forget sometimes what the
engine says that white's just better black has
a super solid position this is a hedgehog setup
where black can kind of slowly remaneuver move the
rook and the bishop and kind of relocate so one of
the things white has to do at some point when you
have a big space advantage just say you know what
i'm not afraid to use it and g4 is a move that
has direct intentions to turn this space advantage
into some sort of king side attack and so um we
see g4 met by knight c5 from magnus to clear up
the d7 square for the night but i like this
aggressive showing here hammer by by artemyev
to say i'm ready to get frisky over here in
this hedgehog and see if i can use my space
yeah it's um but it it can backfire
it's a very committal move white's king
will be left without pawns to defend it and magnus
will try to capitalize on that while artemia
will try to create an attack on black's king and
just pretty much cramp black's position as the
white pawns advance there's going to be less and
less space for the for the black pieces and this
h6 move is a really interesting psychological ploy
from magnus he's trying to provoke artemyev into
going h4 after which magnus will play the move
h5 and he's gonna be like oh oh yeah i was just
moving one forward to provoke you to go further
forward uh and then the knight will jump in behind
white's pawns to create lots of of trouble there
i love that idea i just highlight on the board i
learned something from that that's an instructive
little advanced little pawn maneuver there and uh
artemia does not take the bait he switches
sides and then plays g5 which the risk of that
after h6 everyone is the trade kind of splits the
pawns right normally you would love to have the
h-pawn recapturing here you're forced to take with
the f-pawn where yes you avoid that knight g4 from
magnus but you've really as you said hammer this
is an example where the hedgehog could lead to a
crushing win maybe g6 comes and the position falls
apart or it could lead to a lot of risky chess
here because white is super committed opening the
king yeah and g6 definitely was artemia's plan
and he plays it without thinking for the fourth
game in a row magnus is down one minute on the
clock and these white knights are about to
infiltrate uh black's position uh the the
night the point of white's last move is trying
to eliminate the defender of the e6 pawn and if
magnus loses this e6 pawn then the other white
knight will also get an opportunity to jump in
in the center and that's just spells disaster for
magnus and i'm not sure how he's going to keep
control of his light squares in this situation no
i agree with you totally and i i feel like this
is a weird position to see the eval only plus one
for white because our human brain of the hedgehog
feels like white has gotten everything they
desire right they've gotten the tactics on
the light squares they're taking advantage of this
lack of space from black and these e6 tactics are
are all too common everyone in games where
white rolls to a victory in the hedgehog so
we'll see yeah and i was gonna say i was gonna
say i think magnus needs to bring the king out
magnus is not in the position where you normally
would like to involve the king but sometimes you
just got to do what you got to do and that
king needs to come out to defend the pawn
in the middle yeah he chooses not to take
with the king but that does lose a pawn
i think you were maybe right maybe he should have
taken with the king look at that discipline from
artemyev doesn't even take it with the knight
brings in the piece capable of more damage on
the light squares this looks like a tough game
for magnus yeah great move from artemy up there
magnus down two minutes on the clock i mean
magnus is getting steamrolled in this match
he's just so fortunate that he managed to turn
game two around to equalize the score otherwise
i could easily see artemia being up by two points
maybe even three uh yeah i mean at this point if
he wins this game obviously the math is he'll only
be up by one but again if you're just joining us
the storyline has been artemyev has has been the
guy so far right the score's level but the x's and
o's on the board have been magnus fighting for his
life and down on time pretty consistently today um
this looks like a game acura moves are going to
put this one away hammer so what is it is it yeah
maybe accurate moves will finish it but i have
no idea what an accurate move is i know magnus
was intending to give up his rook if artemyev
brought his bishop into the fray uh so probably
great decision there by the russian to use the
knight instead he's not afraid of knight f3
even though it looks kind of terrifying um yeah
because i guess he's just gonna move the king
yeah let's let's analyze it real quick i think
again hammer's first point about bishop takes
likely being met with rook takes here is really
interesting because black might suddenly get
some compensation you know even if he's still
worse on the light squares so the fact that this
was played we said this check not a threat
because in the end you can't take the rook
before the queen has to be dealt with so
instead magnus plays queen takes c4 holy
holy you know what he's he's all in i mean magnus
is like well i think i'm gonna lose this one
i have to try to create some tactics but you see
what the computer says in an equal position this
guy's hanging right there's all kinds of tactics
on the light squares here the queen is hanging
probably a simple move ends this game pretty
quickly yeah but magnus is about to give up
his queen magnus's main problem is the time he's
down to just 10 seconds and here he chooses to
exchange um in wow and artemis doesn't even take
magnus's queen he takes magnus's rook and then
he takes the knight wow that white knight really
went on a crusade against magnus's position there
in in the space of three moves that knight
took a bishop a brook and another knight
it was the hero of the game and it once again
has given artemyev uh the lead they say white
knighting is frowned upon these days but in this
case goes all in takes everything with check
before before recapturing the queen and just like
that the white knight delivers the goods not only
is artemia up a piece but he's still still the
one on the attack what what a finish by the way
and again if you're looking at a model game for
white uh in a hedgehog you might want to replay
vladislav varchima's performance in this game
a few times so all right we're back to the uh
the next game vladislav artemyev is putting
on a show right now magnus carlsen fighting
for his life and i think we're going to
i think we're going to have a thriller
today i'm going to guess both these matches
magnus carlson and vladislav archamia cara
coming up right after this so you have
a full day of chess tv ahead of you
i think both these matches are going to give
us give us what we what we signed up for
and i want to make a little point here danny
i said we have seen magnus's king's pawn
for the last time and guess what the
black rice artemia have got the advantage
using the karo khan opening two times in a
row and magnus has gone away from that opening
he artemia with the black pieces
actually forced magnus out of his plan a
and here instead magnus's plan b is a similar
position because he once again appreciates his
bishops uh so magnus with the two bishops trying
to break down the the solid pawns of artemyev uh
i was going to say even though what you
said is true you avoided the kero khan
this is a structure that is eerily similar
in some ways right given the way it went
yeah but the the main thing that's different from
the first two games is the computer evaluation uh
which during the cover con was mostly in black's
favor as opposed to here when the computer is a
massive fan of magnus's position right a great
point let's bring up the analysis board just to
highlight the advanced uh or for those just tuning
in hammer's main point was that magnus had played
e4 and run into artemis kero khan and not only
failed to get advantage was worse with white
several games in a row hammer called it if you
just tuned in and indeed magnus agreed it was time
to switch so we went for a semi-slavin and as i
was highlighting even though the structure is very
similar in some ways to the kero con white has
the bishop pair versus the solid setup hammer's
totally right white space advantage is completely
different here the grip on the dark squares the
huge pawn storm this looks like a maybe a rebound
game for carlson who as you said hammer he doesn't
like to lose two games in a row yeah and we
discussed it before the match started avoi getting
two wins in a row that's the way to shake magnus
but it's an incredibly difficult thing to do
and um uh our tamiya here under pressure um
i would say for the first time in the match
that's funny because he's the underdog but i agree
with you 13 000 on twitch almost 7 000 on youtube
thanks for being here the day has only just begun
and as you can see the favorite uh in the in
this particular battle is uh currently currently
trailing but there's a fort coming on e5 get your
emotes out um what does black what does mike do on
this this is really kind of irish he's gonna have
to retreat right with the bishop or the knight
one or the other yeah i'm gonna guess the bishop
moving away so that you open up for the rook uh
to put pressure into the middle but i'm not sure
i thought maybe move that bishop to a defensive
position right instead artemyev has moved it up
uh in an attacking position the problem with that
being that magnus he controls that part of the
board and now magnus's pawns are gonna push that
bishop around until it has nowhere left to go and
uh magnus right now trying to figure out whether
artemyev is a genius uh planning to sacrifice
his bishop to eliminate the pawns protecting
white's king or if uh he's just gifting him
uh um a nice position i i agree with you i love
that you said he's trying to figure out is artania
but genius or is he blundering his bishop right
although what's funny is i think carlson could
even play bishop e3 here if you want to be safe
subtle and just hold the big center together
that would prevent lines let's bring up okay
bishop let's bring up the analysis board to
prove my point which is b4 the big problem
with this in a lot of ways is not just that
this happens but also likely a third pawn falls
so magnus doesn't play bishop e3 but bishop b1
is along the same lines of what i was suggesting
just defend the pawn now this is probably a real
threat and i think artemyev is still in a very
tough spot having to figure out what to do with
this uh with this situation and if artemiev now
has to give up his bishop for white's knight
it proves why he should have gone on the defensive
with his bishop instead of moving it up the board
right moving pieces into enemy territory is
not always a good idea sometimes you need to
uh take care of your own situation first right
and i i think we're getting a good demonstration
of that here i'm showing your idea hammer because
it's it's a great one there that hammers point is
a retreating move was probably better just because
it actually makes magnus's life a little more
tricky for just pure example bishop b1 would just
lose the pawn so um not not totally that simple
but i'm with you it it feels like bishop b4 to
a5 was a little bit too aggressive there um from
martin and before he regrets in four games in a
row magnus has been down one minute on the clock
but we're seeing a turn in the trends right here
artemia for the first time down on the clock
down on position as well for the first time
which is amazing because he's playing game five
against the world champion but i want to
remind everyone that maksudu had a 2-2 score
after four games but that's when the beast awoke
in carlson uh when uh with the world champion
winning 10 games in a row after that um artemyev
needs to be at his very best throughout this match
uh because magnus he's just getting warmed up
and he's gonna be able to play amazing chess
for the next two hours as well uh a one point lead
isn't gonna be enough for the russian grand master
well said and a good reminder for every one of
what happened in that previous mug subu match e5
gaining it's so funny to see how well he's played
this center meeting magnus because i you know
maybe it's not funny i would never play that well
but i like that he's been patient he hasn't tried
to rush b4 and give our timmy what he wants which
is the sacrifice back so just take a note everyone
right the patience he displays with the space um
is really going to make our timbi's life tough
and if we're looking for a turnaround hammer this
is a big moment for our champion if he was down
on the clock down in position and it's all because
of what you called d4 played by magnus instead of
e4 so so if this is a sign of things to come
will this be the game that awakens the beast
wow and look at magnus's patience i thought magnus
had the right opportunity to to go trap that
bishop on the edge of the board but magnus doesn't
want any funky business he doesn't want to weaken
the situation around his own king and he's just
letting that black knight stay on the edge and
in fact magnus now threatening g4 the knight has
nowhere to move and artemium is gonna have to uh
do some uh some special work uh to get that knight
just off the rim yeah i think we're gonna say do
some gymnastics mental gymnast which is what
he's having to do here he has to he plays g5
trying to create some sort of uh pole vaulting
jump board get this get this knife back in here
but i i will hammer will magnus continue to
be patient and keep the knight deadlocked
f5 is also a move to consider um yeah i don't
think magnus can keep then the knight out if
magnus moves his pawn forward then there's to be
an exchange of pawns no maybe the knight let's
analyze it real quick because there's also
this other knight coming back to d5 right
if f5 there's like a captures and to be careful
black has things like yeah or coming in yeah oops
yeah a big moment in in the match here because
magnus took a full minute to consider and it
it appears he didn't find something he was
fully uh happy with because now artemyev
back in the game has the time advantage magnus
is down on the clock and now g6 from artemyev is
crucial magnus now with a trap if artemia captures
the white pawn which he's very tempted to do
then magnus will push his pawn forward and the
knight is trapped on the edge of the board instead
artemia first gets that escape route for the
knight and then is gonna try to get it back into
the game we're gonna have one of those exciting
finishes where both players are down to 20 seconds
this is where magnus excelled in his previous
match and this is where artemyev needs to show
that he can do better uh what is going on why
can you not capture that pawn i have no idea but
and the pawn is gone i don't know what magnus was
doing i mean h4 was was brilliant and then g4 to
follow gives up the point that was fascinating
i don't we won't have time to make sense of it
because as you said hammer we're gonna have one of
those exciting finishes here we go now down a pawn
on the board in addition the black knights have
excellent squares uh the only problem for black
is that he's completely cramped up on the bottom
um rows of the board wow bishop so magnus even
though being down uh wow the attack would have
been opening up for the queen against the bishop
so tricky and now are timmyev oh
and now the knight is coming out
into the attack and magnus is in trouble a
game where magnus thought he had everything
under control is turning around for him
both players down to less than 10 seconds
on the clock magnus desperately trying to get
some counter attack and frankly succeeds with
it magnus eliminating one of black's pawns on the
side and going after another one uh and artemia
he gets the chance to get that crucial second
win in a row but he blunders and magnus with
the extra bishop now gonna equalize the match
yeah we've said it we said it just as the match
was about to start magnus has been so good
in the stressful situations and once again
he shows that he can keep his nerve
as the seconds countdown and his queen
is about to put some hurt on black's king and
this was a game that could have gone either way
but in the end uh magnus avoids losing
two games in a row and he takes the win
i wow you brought it home there and i i
i couldn't agree more how huge that was
because it was that crucial game where artemyev
might have gotten two games in a row right he
might have gotten that second win but he
fails to do so and we are back to level
what a game right it was weird because it was
a game we thought magnus was going to win but
then artemi have completely turned it around
if this is the story line hammer then magnus
is doing what he did against mogsulu right he's
playing better in those crucial time scrambles
and that doesn't bode well for our chimney
of as the time controls get faster but okay
a lot a lot of chess left to be played we still
have 30 minutes here in the five minute portion
just so excited this is so exciting yeah and
remember this may have been the turning point
in the match magnus uh can be intimidating
uh when he gets his groove on when he gets
the the small margins in his favor and
once again i want to remember that after
uh magnus won the fifth game of his previous match
against matsudulu he actually continued to win
nine more consecutive games uh artemyev needs to
reset after that disappointing game he knows that
he was in a winning position he knows how close he
was to take a big lead against the heavy favorite
but now he needs to deal with the disappointment
of that defeat and and just move on as if nothing
had happened right and and that is what's
so difficult about the speed chess format
is because the games are consecutive because there
are no breaks for the players having a good mental
being able to to cope with a defeat uh avoiding
two losses in a row uh it's so crucial right
yeah no and you know we said that
i think our champion does have that
that quality i like to say that the great
ones have which is short-term memory loss
you know they're so confident they don't
tend to dwell on their mistakes so i
i believe that he has that but this is going to be
a test because that was much more heartbreaking i
think than that first loss he had so um all right
here we go we've got a b3 system by the way i just
wanted to bring up the analysis board to back
up because yesterday we talked about aronian
trying to go full hikaru a few times with this
b3 blitz specialty but i will say artemia even
more than aronian actually plays these things
right regularly we know he also placed the king's
indian attack regularly for those who followed the
speech s grand prix uh that i covered most of the
events for this year so this is not quite uh levon
aronian's approach i'm not not being so familiar
with b3 i actually like the position artemia
has achieved here um out of the first few moves
uh and those bishops on the side of the board
i always find fascinating because i tell people
you need to place your pieces in the middle
but in fact bishops are best when they're on
the side when they're in those piano positions
because they're pointing in towards the middle
so it's not about where you place your pieces
it's about what squares they control and bishops
are of that sort where being on the side
is the way they control towards the middle
and we see this sort of uh you know staring
contest here between the dark square bishops
artemia plays h4 i really like that move as
a way to sort of expose black's retreat of
the knight to e8 um magnus might even try to
fix that with the knight g7 i don't know but
but h5 is a is a real threat here um and okay
so he plays bishop g4 to defend it but watch out
for this uh how does our timmy approach it here
hammer i would be very tempted to play knight e5
and there he goes uh the knight putting pressure
on the black bishop putting pressure on the black
knight a magnus is going to have to exchange
after which the white queen gets in there into
the middle of the board a threat combined with the
knight on e7 uh there's some scary stuff going on
and we're so connected right now the psychic
invasion of each other like i'm like i'm like
camped in your brain and you're camped in
mind and we're not even mad about we're
like hey how you doing right i mean we
are all over this i'm highlighting moves
a split second before you say it um and now h5
from artemyev wow magnus in a bad situation once
again and it's a return to the initial four games
with uh he played knight f4 up on time yeah yeah
yeah he's back to the uh again original rd if
you're just tuning in was vladislav up on time
that last game was sort of a a sign of baby magnus
finding it but no we're right back at a position
our champion is better i agree with you hammer
i think h5 was also possible but knight f4
pretty good as a tempo move to hit the
bishop and magnus defending once again
uh and yeah h5 definitely still on the agenda
for artemyev wow he chooses to strike on both
sides of the board simultaneously uh the the
white pawn on the side just pushing its way
up uh it's gonna allow white to get the rook
into play despite not having moved that rogue
from the corner um and magnus now under
pressure on both sides of the board
and not for the first time in this match he's
gonna be down two minutes on the clock i've never
seen magnus being uh pressured uh like artemiev
is doing here on the clock and now should
change queens put the knight in the center
and then push the pawn forward on the side
of the board great play from artemia
yeah i totally agree and artemium is
he's one of those guys who has made a name
for himself i think more this year hammer than
than he would have in other years not just because
of you know online chances always existed but the
focus like due to the due to the global pandemic
um people are getting to know this guy and he's uh
russia has a lot of really talented super gm's who
don't always play in in the elite invitationals
and this guy's one of them um okay b5 is a
reactive move from magnus i really like that
he's not allowing the a file to become open but
artemia is still better if he finds the right
approach is it to take and gang up on an isolated
c pawn is it knight d5 first what do you think
um i'm really unsure it's it's a good move
from magnus he's trying to get his knight
into the middle of the board right and now
knight d4 next from magnus is such a good
good move for him that knight is going to be so
well placed i don't really see how artemyev is
is going to deal with that i would say he
should put his knight in the center as well
but then what's next how does
he stop magnus from getting
the knight into d4 i think the answer is he can't
uh so then the question needs to be how does he
prepare for magnus about to move the knight in and
i'm not sure that was it oh he has rook a2 okay
so with magnus moving the knight up there's
a double threat of a fork in two directions
uh so but artemia manages to defend against
both those threats by moving his rook up he
needs to get rid of magnus's knight pronto
um but he can play e3 now okay and he does
i like that because one thing to recognize is 96
might run into e4 and f3 trapping the bishop so
um where does magnus put that knight if you go to
c6 hammer c5 falls so i like this move well magnus
is going to put the knight on b5 and now he has
the pressure against the pawn on d3 which is the
disadvantage of moving forward and now magnus
has the option of capturing said pawn and look
at that look at magnus's eyebrows right there i'm
not sure he had seen that rook move from artemyev
exploiting the fact that the bishop and knight
couldn't go into that relationship where they
were both dependent well let's show it on the
announcement because i want to see the tactic i
think i think i know the answer will show everyone
else i think bishop d3 would be met by knight f4
yeah that's the idea everyone is the bishop can't
stay on this diagonal safely and guard the knight
at the same time so um it was played very quickly
magnus calculating super quickly that he couldn't
take the pawn so just want to show that for
everyone but but even if he didn't take it hammer
right looking at the analysis board this is still
a position that you know magnus is holding whoa
c4 um well i think magnus is under big pressure
uh though i must say magnus was not expecting
artemia to make that pawn exchange uh now the
night the night comes into play attacking both
the rook and the pawn and it seems like artemiev
is just shutting down this game for business
trading off the remaining pieces and it looks
as though magnus despite being under pressure
both on the board and on the clock uh he's about
to secure a draw and keeping the the match tied
yeah and despite the timing disadvantage too
which we've been highlighting that magnus was not
um not up on the clock again like he was in the
uh the last game but if he holds hammer he gets
white again and we've seen how well he he played
in that in that d4 slot so this is this is a good
draw i think for magnus's black given that he puts
artemia in a position to prove that he can do the
same yeah and it's it's not the artemyev we saw
earlier where he he understood that once he has
the time advantage against magnus he really
needs to put pressure uh artemyev here just
trading pieces despite being a minute up on the
clock that suits uh calls him just fine and let's
look at the analysis board to see maybe where
he could have gone wrong because it was right
here with the c4 move where our timmy have made
that decision you said to just start trading and
ultimately he went for this massive simplification
what was the move he could have gone for on c4
instead is the question uh well i wanted e4 um
e4 and then maybe g4 yeah yeah i i was actually
going to go e5 after i kicked the knight even
better yeah just try to push black's pieces
back right um okay and but instead magnus got what
he wanted and now they're just having a trade show
rachel on the main board ratios which are actually
underrated fun by the way if you ever want to go
to a trade show and just sit in the back you
know we got 500 here just bid bid low anyway
i don't even know if that is a trade show anyway
would you say twitchcon qualifies as a trade show
which con is it racial is it i don't know would
you say it qualifies i guess so i mean stuff you
know um i got some free swag while i was there
which felt good um yeah so yeah which gun sure
all right here we go we're back in a slob and
again if you're just tuning in everybody the early
story line magnus played e4 failed against against
our champions carol khan switched to d4 and had a
pretty big advantage last game so with this match
leveling out despite the fact that i think you and
i would agree still hammer that artemia has played
probably overall the better chess so far right but
magnus does seem to be finding his groove you
know what happened when stella got her groove
back saved tay diggs career if you know what i'm
talking about right so could be happening right
now i i've been thinking about our last time
broadcasting together danny and uh a lot of
the times you would make jokes and i wouldn't
laugh at all and i think part of the reason
is that your references are either too old for me
which would be devastating for you or too american
which would be devastating considering
that we're now broadcasting at 9 00 a.m
uh on the east coast right so you need to tone
down your american references and then start
getting with the times it's europe baby and stella
got her groove back baby and angela bassett hasn't
been heard from since but if you don't even get
that reference i don't even know what to tell you
all right well i'm a european danny okay okay all
right so what happened one night let's bring up
the analysis board i'm all with you okay 94 was
played by the way everyone and taking is not an
option because after captures you got a problem
here it's called a pin and it's gonna win for
black so of course magnus retreats instead and
now we're in this semi-slub not the same as as
game what was that game five i guess hammer but
where we had the the castles long from magnus so
what's going on in this relatively similar
symmetrical structure with d5 currently hanging
i don't really know what happens if you
take that point okay i'll i'll show you this
if queen takes you take here removing that it
did see danny and you winnie two would check was
that a rhetorical question you tricked me into
pretending you didn't know what was going on
no because this one i don't know because i
have a bishop about to capture your knight
and the evaluation bar jumped oh yeah it's a
favor oh yeah so why can't you take is it oh
maybe it's that's what i'm asking you danny
oh okay i you know as the i am in the room i
can never tell whether i'm being talked
down to by the gm's i hang out with so
um thank you for giving me real respect and asking
me a question that i failed to have the answer to
uh but uh magnus decides that capturing the pawn
is too tricky and instead chooses to uh put some
pressure on the black bishop on the side of the
board once again i would say for like the fourth
white game in a row magnus is trying to get the
bishop pair which of course i'm a big fan of it's
just that magnus hasn't really been able to do
anything with those bishops thus far yeah it's
not the bishop pair that you uh you write home
and tell mom about they're currently currently uh
you know back on the back rank so and i think this
brilliantly demonstrates what i was talking
about in the previous game that even though
the bishops are located in the middle of the
board in the central files they're pointing out
towards the edges of the board right and with
bishops it's all about where they're pointing
not where they're placed so let's go back to
this knight takes d5 thing what is the reason
yes it's got to be bishop e6 yeah yeah i i would
guess that as well and then when the bishop comes
up to defend with bishop c4 probably knight
d6 yeah i was just gonna say that yeah putting
additional pressure on those white pieces but
but it is tricky and and so it's it's optically
optically a little bit trickier to figure out why
knight takes d5 fails that first meets the eye
bishop b5 can probably be met by knight a5
although in that case look at this hammer
the bishop is gone from check so what magnus
is doing is actually threatening to take on d5
for the first time everyone again reminder
taking here would lose the knight takes c3
with tempo it removes the defender of the
queen and again i have a little vision zoo
because they say in between move i take with
check so this movement meso as i like to say
not trying to sound like yes or inter meso jen
yeah yeah exactly exactly janet's an intermittent
you got a european audience now you
gotta get they know german pronunciation
okay queen takes d5 i like it and again everybody
the point is knight takes c3 you can trade on d8
right because there's no knight takes e2
with chip does that work for you yeah and
i'm wondering what was artemia's plan against
this uh because he just lost the pawn straight up
no cap as my kids would say
straight up lost a pawn no cap
you know what that means or am i
cooler than you all of a sudden
i i i have i'm familiar with the expression yes
thank you my 15 year old told me last night when
i said no cap at dinner he said you're no longer
allowed to say that you you are you anyway um
people are like 15 year old what yeah trickiness
is about to happen here yes uh artemia just
offered a knight to magnus um and what's happening
then because if you capture the knight the bishop
is going to force the white queen away i think
we're going to need the analysis board for this
yeah let's do it let's bring it up bishop takes
c6 oh okay he didn't play but bishop takes c6 was
going to be met by bishop e6 i assume no i don't
think so danny because then the queen can move
right and then when the rook captures you get
that pawn with a fork do i have the fork emote
you're not wrong although i don't know
that actually winning i think black has
weird moves that he's maybe holding on with
either way magnus he makes this i guess
mature decision not to go all in retreats and says
hey i didn't need your knight because i won a pawn
yeah and he's respecting the bishops which i
respect i love that he respects the bishop you'd
respect him a lot of respect flowing around by the
way the threat in that position was e6 trapping
the unrespected lady in the center so 95
frees the f3 square as a retreating move
yeah so magnus got the pawn but his
queen got stuck in a precarious situation
and now artemyev is about to kick that queen
back and then try to get back the pawn he
what the he's got bishop
before dude that's the idea
but why is the computer still
giving advantage for white
i have no idea that trouble
nineteen you have stuff
the queen gets out there's a
counter threat against black's queen
the temple analysis board analysis board the
point everybody is if knight takes you get here
and if you take the queen i still end up being up
material or do i am i just down a piece no i'm up
the exchange i forgot i have two rooks and if
you take with the rook i guess it's queen e6
i don't know and artemia chooses to do
neither of those things what is going on
double check there's no by the way no
queen g8 everyone because night guards f7
but magnus got his queen out of a bad situation
while simultaneously defending his knight on the
edge of the board and right now artemia is down
two pawns and a rock in exchange for a knight and
that's just not good enough well and he's rubbing
his eyes i'm the guy who woke up at 4 am buddy
um let's bring back the analysis board to
show how crazy that was this move queen c7
i think was based on knight h6 check maybe maybe
our timmy have just missed queen g5 straight up
everyone queen g8 was not a threat because the
knight guards f7 don't fall for a failed venus
flytrap i think artemis just missed queen
g5 just based on his reaction right hammer
well he must have and now magnus pushing the pawns
forward in the center this is a highway uh to the
win and for the first time in this match magnus
is gonna take the lead who had that on their bingo
cards magnus taking the lead in game seven first
of all you just referenced bingo and and i love
you for it just mark that off my bucket list
somebody else makes an unnecessary pop culture
reference on a chest show um that was great no
you're right who had that and again hammer's
not joking everyone magnus has not led in this
match that's likely going to change right here
and hammer i feel like you're pro this is
why we had you with these magnificent matches
just for show knight f7 just for show queen e5
and then knight oh queen of five and then knight
f7 let me let me show it on the analysis
board you predicted it so well he does it
knight f7 and the knight is pinned everyone
uh okay even better night g4 even better
and magnus about to win this game about to take
the lead in the match and artemyev has given away
a lot of big chances so far uh he needs
to let that slide uh mental uh uh acuity
that's what it's all about now and and he needs to
um just concentrate on the position ahead of him
and and forget all about the numerous chances
he has had uh to uh to get the the up on
on magnus yeah it's hard it's easier said than
done right although there is only 10 minutes
left before a break so maybe with a chance
to refresh himself before he wrecks himself
artemyev will uh we'll play some good chess on
the three one portion he's already kind of over
performed what uh the smarter chess predictions
were for the five-minute portion saying magnus
should be three games better so take that smarter
chess uh by the way go to chessgoals.com you can
use the command chess goals so even though
we make fun of smarter chess go ahead and
head over to chess goals and get guidance
towards your chess improvement a lot of a
lot of us need that we got 22 000 of you plus
on twitch 9 000 of you almost on youtube and
we love every one of you literally hammer loves
every one of you like yeah look at that smile
um and this might be the very last
game uh of the five minute portion
which means if magnus is able to take
two in a row and get an amazing finish
in the five minutes once again the the results
will uh lie about what's going on in the match
because this five minute uh section has been all
about what is yet the score doesn't accurately
reflect that because magnus has been the best
player in the crunch uh when uh you're down
on time and um and yeah i i think it's absolutely
crucial for our temiev now to uh to make sure that
he's uh at least with a draw here uh in this game
uh to uh to feel like he's still within striking
distance of of magnus going into the three-minute
portion i like i like that you said that because i
think it's good chess advice uh as a guy who's
played in world elite events speaking for you
sometimes you just gotta stop the bleeding so
you're saying artemia even a draw is okay now
he is white of course he'd love a w and tie
this thing before the three minute portion
starts but sometimes your mindset has to be like
hey all right i know i've missed opportunities but
don't don't let this thing slip away don't tilt
don't tilt early um and 85 is that about g5 uh
g5 danny i'm not sure i like your chess instincts
a g5 looks horrible the black king already with a
white rook pointing down towards it now you want
to weaken its positioning once you get castled
let's see what the engine thinks who agrees with
it analysis board we go let's see who likes g5
oh so you're just telling me okay you were
right the engine likes white on g5 okay um
what were we talking about again once again
danny i want to say uh you know your confidence
is admirable if misplaced thank you well um
knight e5 does threaten to take d7 just to
explain my thought process you can't take with
the knight because it's pinned and if you take
with the queen i take on f6 and double your pawn
so i'm trying to deal with that maybe i just
back up to e7 it threatens pretty much everything
danny but i'm wondering what happens on bishop c3
that has to be the the attempted punishment oh
let's do it now if the bishop can get in there
uh both the rook and no strike that danny
uh artemy have just sacrificed his rook
knight d takes c4 what the bleep look at
that bishop takes e1 is met with knight to d6
and the wtf's hit the chat why the face why the
face magnus but is magnus now just gonna castle
magnus's king is in a real state right now but
uh on the other hand the computer evaluation
uh is very much more black than white meaning that
black with the best moves should have an advantage
that being said white has all of
these pieces pointed in towards
uh black's uh queen towards black's king towards
pretty much everything and in addition to that
magnus is severely down on time he's down two
and a half minutes on the clock uh with his king
in trouble uh this might be the epic comeback
and the kind of win artemiev needs right now
if he can win in style equalize the score going
into the three-minute portion he's gonna be on a
real high with magnus wondering what on earth just
happened this man just completely annihilated me
well b5 is played wtf now means where's the fork
because it no longer exists the bishop guards d6
but there is no chekaruski here um b5 is a heads
up i mean look at this position there were a lot
of ways it could go wrong taking e1 allowing this
move would have been bad for magnus as i showed
quickly uh castles is bad because the king gets
blown open and and here we go so magnus finds
the cool headed b5 kicking the knight while
you guard d6 and this rook is still hanging so
i know you went i know you went hype champ over
there on artemium's comeback but i'm gonna say
i think magnus is going to kenbe mutumbo on
that not in my house look at that move b5
people outside of no that's not entirely true but
i'm not too familiar with basketball hey the u.s
is kind of the home of basketball every doorway
norway rising basketball capital of the world you
i called it here 20 30. um anyway um be fine i i
think i deserve some credit just for knowing that
that guy was a basketball player that's probably
because you've subscribed to my channel and you
got that mutumbo emo now you talk because i
get to use my emote for the first time today
uh but artemia now taking a long think uh
there's so many pieces under attack right
now and vladislav is going to have to give up
at least one of them um but the question is
which one he opens up for the rogues on the edge
of the board uh he's probably gonna make the trade
and what's happening then is magnus gonna move
the queen away from the protection of the king
i have no idea what's going on but
artemia really should have an idea
because he spent two and a half minutes
considering the uh consequences of his play
yeah and the time is still undecided it's gone
right um you were highlighting earlier the time
advantage and its position is still close to
level although it's one of those level positions
according to the computer and humans are like
what is going on here there's a million pieces
hanging and so this is one of those positions i'm
just going to predict the next move within
the next three moves the eval bar hammer
is just going to go nut like someone's going
to blunder here you can't maintain balance
and time pressure in such a nutty position
yeah but i think artemia is going to blunder
because the fact that he spent so much time means
that he cannot find anything he's happy about
which means he's probably just gonna end up in
a bad position and the eval bar supporting that
in the first uh in the first move magnus
actually moving his queen away from the king
despite the king desperately needing protection
uh he's magnus is just happy to get that queen
away from white's bishop that was pointing
in uh dangerously towards the queen
yeah you i mean you called it and i've been i
was highlighting taken with the queen because
of the battery earlier and now i wonder if that
pawn is just capturable by the way with only a
minute left more than likely this is the last game
of the time control one of your last chances to
subscribe throw us your prime to see what happens
in our prime time smackdown this week we got
wrench versus hammer a couple of tools huh a
couple of tools in the old tool shop throwing
around wrench and hammer and i think magnus should
castle now to get the king into safety and he does
do that magnus now with the safer king with the
better pawn structure with more time on the clock
yes he's a pawn down but look at those bishops
pointing in towards white's position we've had a
big turn around magnus was on the defensive now
he's given up upon gotten his king into safety
and now it's his bishops ruling the board creating
trouble for artemyev and it's looking as though
magnus is about to get two in a row here finishing
the five minute time control of really seizing
the moment uh and uh getting a big advantage going
into the first break well said it'd be it would oh
uh magnus moving in the forces towards white's
king artemyev tries to do the same with his queen
but oh there was a knight magnus just captures
the knight and with that he wins a piece
uh he tries to create some counter checkmating
threats here artemyev but magnus moving his
knight back seems to have things under control
because now you can capture the rook i was
going to say even bishop c8 was a funny move
anyway but what he does is good enough clearly
artemia runs out of pieces and magnus winning
two in a row we talked about how crucial it is
to to get that a big advantage of of tilting the
opponent while at the same time getting a solid
lead in the match magnus just did it he had a slow
start but he's getting there and he's going to be
lethal in the three-minute portion as well it's
crucial for artemyev to keep this distance of just
two points magnus is capable of running away with
it and and that has to be uh artemia's artemyev's
priority right now to to just stop this good face
magnus is in uh well said it and i and i do agree
that if artemia keeps it close the bullet could be
anyone's game because vladislav is so effective as
a as one of the top bullet players on chess.com
so all right you set the table for what three
minute needs to be for both these guys i'll set
the table for the break prime time smackdown
between wrench and hammer coming your way uh don't
go anywhere everyone when we return it's more
speed chess championship on this double header
day today we'll be back in just a few minutes
okay hammer are you ready to are
you ready to feel bad about yourself
i just want to say that when my kids when i get
kids i want them to be as as bold and brave as you
volunteering to play me in a bullet match
knowing you're gonna get destroyed right
it's it's it's an admirable trait well i've
also people have also said like danny how come
you have no pride how come you self-deprecate
so much how come you put yourself
in masochistic situations so you
want them to have those straights too
this is the i suppose i'm eating i guess dude
i know this is going to sound shocking to you
and the audience i don't plan on losing to you
bro i don't plan on let's go ready okay let's go
oh my god i forgot you play
this crap what is your deal
yeah how about that you like that about
that how about that how about uh no
this is a winning position for white like
yeah that's right i forgot you play crap
you play crap and then you know the crap so well
that it's hard to compete with the crowd i think
that's you will find that's a pawn up for me
i'm up to here with your crap how about that
ah interesting a bad move by you
have your pawn thank you this is one of
those positions that should be worse for me
than it is but you messed up so bad
because you're so distracted by me
i think you will find that's not really what's
happening here i think you will find that you
need to respect the bishops and you have failed to
do so in this game i need to respect the bishops
i don't need to respect the bishops you
need to respect the bishops i am though
he thought you were going to get d4 check
i actually did give you d4 check that was
so irritating oh it's so funny oh my gosh
okay thank you i was so focused on fast fun do i
hate you i hate you right now i hate you so much
no i mean i can even tell you what moves you
should play and you still don't play them
i wasn't even looking for
d4 anymore i had too much i
i literally made you aware that was an option
okay well guess who gets the white pieces now bro
and we are back here yet again as the first speed
chess championship match of the day between magnus
carlson and vladislav artemyev moves to the
three-minute segment but not before we remind
all of you to move your schedules tomorrow it's
tgif it's bob battles we got younger and creepier
john travolta on the left along with uh you know
something robert hess would never look like which
is organized and clean-shaven on the right it's
gonna be quite the day tomorrow hammer uh yeah i'm
looking forward to it i i i maintain that robert's
uh depiction was was pretty decent at least
compared to yours but you know i mean your body
is going to get one hell of a beating tomorrow
that's a european reference and i'm going to
continue making european references for the rest
of this match okay okay yeah all right predictions
we've got we've got three minutes coming up here
um again six to four predicted in the three-minute
portion uh we've again magnus carlsen is the
favorite and pretty much every time control but
as you said artemia really just needs to focus on
stop the bleeding don't tilt even if you keep it
within just a couple games for bullet the fastest
segment maybe where you have to make your move
right yeah all right now having lost two games in
a row it's all about uh mental and being able to
just continue how he's been playing so far without
thinking too much about the disappointing results
he's had honestly the the three minute the five
minute section was evenly matched uh if anything
i would say artemiev was maybe the better player
but magnus showing his uh how good he is in those
decisive moments takes or comes away with a two
game lead uh meaning that um if he can just
continue this trend uh he's gonna win the match
also showing how much he can pack it
in right there magnus had a real cheek
fold there that's a nice strong jaw when
you can fit that much food in your mouth
and still managed to chew it down with no swelling
did you see that the picture he had on facebook
danny he had his birthday brunch a couple of days
ago that that plate was packed i i'll tell you
yeah well uh all right we're gonna have a
packed show for the rest of the day so don't
go anywhere still more than half ahead and
then we have nakamura versus fedo say it but
here we go the three minute begins in uh
five four three two one we have liftoff
and magnus once again starting with the white
pieces but he has been moved off his plan a
uh initially he was playing the the king pawn
openings but artemyev's karo khan was just
too strong and magnus chose to switch uh
to the the queen pawn openings now i'm not
seeing magnus make any moves here and his e and
his connection bar has dropped big time right
yeah is he even aware the game has i don't think
so maybe the team can give him tell him to refresh
or something he seems to have uh lost connection
with the oh there he goes now he's oh wow
and now he's very unhappy yeah
i don't know what happened there
he lost his connection and now
is he aware it's his move or
and a decision has been made okay we're
gonna we're gonna restart the game apparently
not not apparently it wasn't wasn't magnus's
uh fault there i think we're gonna abort and
restart the game there we go okay so something
happened there but either way all is well that
restarts well as far as the chess.com server
goes am i right all right let's uh let's keep
this thing stable and clean today everybody
um and once again magnus using that queen pawn
because that has given him the results he needs
the king pond not helping out today the queen pawn
put to the test and magnus uh i think he won two
white games in a row uh and he's going to try to
continue that trend yep he plays uh this c6 and
e6 carol khan often that being vladislav artemia
by the way this is something we've seen him do
on a regular basis he also employs the a6 slav
um for those of you just wondering about
artimus repertoire he's very consistent i'll
say that some players on line hammer are kind
of all over the place but artemia vis is is not
gonna vary i think from the slav all day even if
magnus has success that's not really his style
and he loves putting his pawns on the light
squares both against the queen pawn openings
but also the king pawn openings and here he's only
one move away from having all eight pawns on the
light squares but that would bode poorly for
his uh light squared bishop which is currently
trapped in behind all of these pawns so he's gonna
need to breathe some life into that uh bishop's
uh potential and he's decided to do so by trying
to go e5 so moving his rook in towards the center
clearly he's intending to move the pawn forward
which will also be very helpful to his bishop
which then gets a root out of its uh misery
yeah and what you highlighted is is the typical
way this structure goes right it starts out
passive everyone but very often i was just
going to say b3 is a great move that stops it
very often the plan when the exchange happens
is for black to kind of liberate the pieces
with either e5 or c5 in this case he doesn't
have to do it because magnus traded so he takes
with the e pawn making sure at some point the
light square bishop will have life maybe on this
f5 square but what did magnus get in the meantime
pressure against the c6 pawn so instead the bishop
stays stays passive and tucked away defending yeah
really interesting position and i want to point
out that one of the most difficult things about
the speed chess format is adjusting to a new time
control these guys have been spending the last
hour and a half playing five minute games but now
time has been cut they're down to three minutes
each and magnus has not really um his mind hasn't
communicated to his hands that we need to speed up
because magnus once again down on time but it's
much more precarious in the three minute games
because you get into time trouble sooner my mind
also has trouble communicating in my hand on a
regular basis um but in this case i'll leave that
alone um bishop to b2 played kind of passive here
i think that i think that our teammate has gotten
the better of the opening right let's bring up the
analysis board and if we just go back to that
position you first mentioned on rookie 8 with
the tension in the pawns magnus chose to break it
himself by trading on on on d5 but now we notice
again as the bishop eventually came to b7 c5 is on
the agenda for black he gets it well timed and uh
and yeah oh my god we need to move to the board
our attention has sacrificed i want to move
and magnus is shaking his head artemia removing
the pawn in front of white's king the knight
could have been captured uh but then white's king
would have gone on a journey that it was probably
a mating journey if you ask me right uh yeah so
magnus instead chooses to just uh move the rook
and what is going on artemyev leaving the night
where it is because he knows he has the capture
and then the knight attacking both the king and
the bishop and artemyev doing all the tactics
right now he's gonna end up with a pawn extra in
addition to having weakened the defenses around
magnus's king well trying to show the positional
advantages of artemia backfire because i missed
the moment on knight takes f2 but let's go back
to the analysis board again i want to show it
because we did miss it in real time with the show
the whole point was magnus blundered with d takes
c5 missing knight takes f2 again as we said king
takes would have gotten mated and walked up the
board the magnus just tucks his tail between
his legs and knows he's going to lose a pawn
and with it as hammer said black has the extra
peshka and the compensation the dark squares
are weak along with e3 and what what a move
right now from artemia that knight takes f2 and
he could he could bring this back within a game
here yeah i'm proud of our temiev uh showing his
strength there i'm also proud of you danny with
the peshka european reference uh that's russian
russian yeah russia is in europe
you didn't know that right uh
right i mean there's a guy that spent some
time there and i speak a little bit of russian
i don't like i mean i'd i'd rather you refer
to us by the proper name of eastern europe
okay that's fine as long as it's got europe in it
i'm proud of you for uh expanding your horizons on
the references okay well you're welcome in this
position uh artemyev is going to have trouble
expanding his horizons if white maintains control
of the dark squares it's funny magnus defended
despite all the hype there pretty well right i
mean he's going to have the d4 square for the
queen and the knight this bishop isn't ideal as
long as the pawn chain kind of stays this way
so i think magnus is defended decently given
that just outright blunder of knight takes up two
uh yeah but being a down a pawn is still a
problem and the the pawn magnus has on e3
that's uh a loner right there it's what we call an
isolated pawn that is um it cannot be defended by
its other pawn peshka buddies uh which means
no no when we refer to plural it's pesh key
there you go by the way no way i'm getting
corrected on russian grammar right sorry speaking
of the pesky despite artemia having an extra one
i actually still like how magnus defended this
pawn is more of a target and a blocker right of
this bishop here i i'm with you but i feel like
magnus has recovered nicely and could hold this
especially with the mutual time pressure coming
yeah uh no i agree uh great defense from
from magnus um if somewhat cooperative
from our temiev yeah and magnus now just uh trying
to control both sides of the board with his bishop
um ooh but artemia with the bishop coming into
c4 and then he's gonna get his king involved
is a tricky guy he has not given up hope uh
here just yet yeah this is a really strong
idea everybody because let's just foreshadow
if the bishop has to leave this diagonal
look out for the king to run in so magnus
is desperately trying to hold the a4
e8 diagonal artillery of trying to
find a tricky way to get the king in
but are tamiya really down on time yeah and magnus
trying to exploit that um might even try to get an
undeserved win here uh but on the other side wow
artemia is doing a good job on the king side uh
it doesn't seem to be enough though he has a
past pawn um but he's struggling to get that pawn
uh past white's king and it looks as though magnus
has successfully defended and will get a draw
yeah not not a hundred percent yet but i'm with
you it again this bishop is holding two diagonals
every one entry along the b1 h7 point entry along
the a4 e8 point it doesn't seem possible for black
to get the bishop off of both especially with d5
as a target and the threat of the king coming up
so our champion is not this is what you got to do
right we got to applaud him you don't you don't
happy for a draw against the world champion you
got to push this um despite it probably just you
know being a draw yeah but at the same time i feel
like he was way too cooperative in the exchanges
leading uh to this end game where um where he
just let magnus do what magnus wanted to do right
uh and and get this very blocked position where
magnus manages to defend despite being upon down
hold on rex our timmy was trying to
check the king out so the king can get in
yeah magnus now lowest on time just two seconds
remaining hold the horses it's whoa what
only one magnus made that with point five on
the clock by the way okay now he seems to have
recovered on the increment he almost almost
had the draw uh artemia actually offered it
and and magnus declined it but they they reach
at the old-fashioned way with perpetual so i
i'm with you i think magnus um that was more of a
moral victory for magnus than anyone else because
artemia was the one holding the cards and he
kind of let magnus have his defensive way with it
yeah i i think artemyev has been brilliant in this
match he's just not using the chances he's getting
and you know at this level you get punished for
that you don't get that many chances against
magnus and you gotta take them while they're there
yeah robert and i say this a lot in commentary
that sometimes you lose these matches not just
with blunders but you're missed opportunities
right more than anything else and um that
could be one that comes back to haunt him sure
and once again i feel like artemyev i mean
it's tough to say i mean playing against
magnus but i feel like he's being the better
player it's just that he's he's giving away
a lot of points in those crucial time scrambles
and magnus he's so lethal he takes advantage
time and time again and that's why
he's up two points on the score
yeah and one of the things we say about both
magnus and hicarro and others too but those
two guys are always on the top of your brain when
you're talking about these blitz events is is that
they they're the guys who probably they do two
things well they they convert most on those time
scramble opportunities and they persevere the best
when they're worse they create those resourceful
traps and so it ends up being the storyline you
said after the five minute where the scoreboard
five to three magnus after five minute wasn't
necessarily reflective of the quality of
chess but the scoreboard is what matters right
magnus held and got the points when it counted
and um one sign of magnus being under pressure
in this match is how many times he's been down
on the clock and uh as we proceed to the
quicker time controls uh being down on the
clock is going to be uh a growing disadvantage
and here uh our temiev uh he was up 30 seconds
now it's down to 10 seconds but those small time
advantages do matter and um and he just needs to
to start taking the opportunities he's getting in
the time scrambles uh because he's he's playing
well and he's he's uh creating trouble for magnus
through his time management well said we had about
26 000 of you there on twitch we've got 8 000
of you on youtube just tv we see you over there
thank you everyone for your support and uh thanks
for being here we still got a long day ahead i
see some people asking when hikaru plays he plays
right after this match and for those of you that
were with us very early we actually had about a
10 minute delay due to some fair play technical
difficulties so it won't be too long of a break
after this match before hikaro and fedo say
kick off so uh thanks for being with us on this
will now be an scc thursday yeah what a day yeah
all right we've got it good well i i was going
to talk about the finished match which is maybe
inappropriate considering that we got magnus
playing right now and actually i changed my
mind because we're gonna have to talk about the
fact that magnus is already down to one minute
on the clock despite their not even having been
played 20 moves total in this game uh magnus's
time management has been complete shambles
and it just feels like a question of time
before he's um he's punished for it i like this
move rook c8 by the way was threatening a common
kind of hedgehog tactic of knight d4 let's show it
on the analysis board because the advanced players
it's a little bit of an important point something
like this played you have to watch out for this
see the computer loves it for black you take with
the c pawn win the bishop pair and usually have
the compensation with it so artemia immediately
plays queen b1 on rook c8 good little tactical
pattern it brilliantly illustrates that top
players never like having their queens on the same
file as their opponents wrote right and
precisely that theme is what artemy have used now
to open up the position and put pressure on magnus
because magnus made the mistake of putting his
queen on the same file as the white rook and as
a consequence of that um artemiev got his bishop
in a good position pointing down towards black's
camp and now also involving the knight uh artemyev
still up 50 seconds on the clock um is this gonna
be his comeback game uh in that case he can equal
well he cannot equalize the match but he can get
it down to a one point lead for magnus but just as
importantly it will be a huge boost to his uh his
mental that he's been able to to cut magnus's lead
and put pressure on him continuously in these
three-minute games yeah couldn't agree more and no
bishop d6 is releasing the titan if you will over
here on the queen size she's got our eyes on the
b6 pawn and magnus now down to 20 seconds again
yeah magnus is in huge trouble yeah and that is
the comeback game artemia's going
to get it it's going to happen now
into in the time pressure we see magnus kind
of shaking his head just just frustrated with
the way he's played since the start of the
three minute portion you had a freudian slip
a minute ago partner where you almost said
that a win by artemia would tie the match
and that tells you how we feel today everybody
artemiv is right there almost like he should have
won last game right i mean this is artemiev's i
think he has the ability to keep this thing close
and now he needs to be careful about his bishop
the bishop is retreated and magnus inviting the
end game despite being down a pawn should tell you
how much magnus trusts his ability in end games
and artemyev i dislike how he's been spending so
much time here the last couple of moves you should
just get that bishop into e7 attack the black
rook and then come in with the knight as well
magnus being uh pressured here uh by by black by
white and it feels as though this is artemis game
uh but he he wasted his time advantage he spent
too much time and despite being 40 minutes up now
he's uh down by 10 seconds and magnus trying
to get uh rid of as many pieces as he can to
to equalize the um this game yeah now he's trying
to get the the pair of bishops off because the
knight would probably hold its own okay with all
the pawns on one side of the board again no way
artists bishop is trapped it's going to cannot
get out well wait magnus has more than a draw
no it's gonna be equal but whoa wait a second
oh my gosh suddenly black is the one playing
for a win here and i was just gonna say despite
everything we've talked about magnus puts himself
in a position to persevering being resourceful
that the result of this game is not going to end
to indicate uh what most of the moves showed us
which was our timmy have played like a boss but
but like you said hammer he's losing it in these
time scramble crucial moments and i really dislike
that he spent all his time advantage he had
one minute to 20 seconds and he spent it all
without really figuring stuff out i think this
game is still going to be a draw but artemyev
continuously being down to just seconds on the
clock that's uncomfortable yeah and he you could
easily see him uh getting into trouble uh and
uh maybe even uh losing uh and now here's the
pressure magnus is currently putting on white's
pawns and note that magnus is kind of in that
position with house money here hammer right even
though i agree with you objectively should be a
draw the two pieces are better than the rook
everyone when everything is stuck to one side
of the board the rook would rather flex with
multiple past pawns these sort of things so so
magnus can play this position even if he can't
win for quite some time and with very little risk
yeah and i mean he's up by two in the match
so uh spending time on the clock makes sense
as a match strategy but it also makes sense as
a way of putting pressure on artemyev who is
very low on time and continuously has to figure
out how to deal with these new plans magnus is
using and now magnus all the way trying to put his
bishop on the same diagonal as white's uh oh oh uh
yeah i was getting nervous you saw me i tend to
grab my hand i'm nervous i'm working on it well
i thought artemia can go and grab this pawn on the
side ah magnus going f5 f5 is not a good move i do
not like that move yeah it it undoubles and helps
white should still be a draw but this position is
getting a little more double-edged yeah i guess
it was necessary for magnus to do that uh but
artemia getting his king involved look how tricky
the position whoa he was almost frozen there elsa
white white uh almost put him in six one okay
and our tamiya is exchanging down to draw a nice
end this thing the old-fashioned way huh get
get down to just kings and we have a draw wow
what a mess there um but magnus again the
storyline snatching stalemate from the jaws of
defeat holding on yeah but i think what artemia's
problem is now he needs to exploit magnus being
slow to adapt to the new time control and now he's
wasted two good chances in a row we've seen how
lethal magnus is towards the end of these uh time
sections because that's when he has adjusted uh
to the to the time control and i think the more
uh artemyev now uh doesn't manage to cut down
on magnus's lead i i think magnus is gonna have a
really good showing in the last 20 15 minutes of
the three minute portion so uh artemyev needs to
strike while magnus's time management is still um
yeah the uh the time management tends to change
the storyline as we get into bullet right and
sometimes the guy that's been taking a lot of time
magically speeds up in the fastest segment but
i'm with you that overall if artemia keeps this
within a game or two i feel like the bullet is
is quite the coin flip our tim you have so so many
games on chess.com one of the best bullet players
um i think you'll have his chances there and
this is going to be an exciting one because uh
artemia have just sacrificed a pawn on the side
of the board and magnus has taken the challenge
he took the pawn or tamiya trying to claim that
opening up for his rook is going to give him a
long-term compensation uh long-term chances for
the pawn um but we'll just have to wait and see
bishop comes back after stealing the pawn
but artemiev has compensation as hammer
said based on pressure here pressure
on the b file but his pawn is a pawn
and what does artimus do now to prove it because
this is one of those positions it becomes kind of
benko gambidish you give white moves it's queen c2
the rook goes to e1 or d1 we develop and rook b1
so artemia has to find a way to get
long-term compensation now before white
develops and coordinates yeah and what
he just did was a good move that queen
pointing in towards white's king is going to
force magnus to hide out in the corner yeah um
and then you need to get you know the rest of
the pieces involved let's show the analysis
real quick why queen v6 is such a thorn you can't
really develop the bishop to e3 without b2 falling
if you make some random move here comes knight e4
problems with pins on the diagonals so queen b6
a very tricky little move there from martinez and
as hammer said the king tucks itself to bed in the
quarter and now artemia is going to play bishop a6
uh putting the bishops up against each other while
simultaneously getting ready to get the rook uh
that's currently next to black's king get that
over to the other side because that's where
black is attacking right now i played bishop
a6 on the analysis board but we see there on the
live board above the players queen b4 was played
and now we've got this position where black
is putting pressure on e4 before trying to
make some exchanges i i'm not sure what you think
about that um interesting yeah these these uh pawn
sacrifices are very tricky and i think they're
difficult to play for both sides um yeah i felt
like artemyev needed to get that bishop out and
go for the trade because it's not really clear
where that light squared bishop is going to find a
good home uh but artemyev has decided to keep him
uh the bishop on d7 now once again getting out
of the way as the work enters the fray uh and
magnus strikes magnus strikes in the center with
his pawn forcing uh artemyev on the defensive
and magnus's pawns will be weak they're going to
be attacking targets for black but recall that
magnus is up a pawn uh so he can even lose upon
without it being a problem whatsoever look at this
move bishop e3's pointing out that the d6 pawn
has more to worry about than just the e5 punt but
artemyev doesn't miss a beat says i got you bishop
f5 yeah but magnus is gonna sacrifice his rook now
oh man talking dirty to me now you know how i
feel about exchange sacrifices come on um but why
uh because uh he moves you get a really nice
center oh okay so magnus trades first but i
think it just transposes to the variation i was
thinking about well let's analyze the show i think
you're anticipating rook takes whoa i thought
rook takes would be the case but let's knight
takes was just played yeah i was not expecting
that yeah i was expecting brook takes and then
i thought your line would be something like takes
here and i don't even know that you have to sack
the exchange because my point is that there's
moves like 94 with huge centers and c5 problems so
maybe that's what first of all
this thing called uh a submission
oh that's right we talked about that sorry i'm
still struggling with your european language
rook takes bishop takes c5 and then bishop
takes b1 was your idea although funnily enough
do i have moves like this and try to trap
your rook in some cases maybe or maybe not
maybe i just but we got to get back to the game
yeah we've got to get out of being exchanging
stuff the queens are off the board the the pawns
are off the board magnus with two pawns on the
left hand side is going to try to get a new
queen or something and both players down on
time yet again uh magnus with the worst of it but
we've seen how magnus when he's down to 20 seconds
manages to speed up in the crucial moment leaving
artemyev to make the mistakes in the time scramble
agreed agreed agreed knight c4 played kind
of irritating you're threatening forks on d2
as well as tactics on b2 and a3 with
the bishop but okay lots to calculate
brooks c1 only 11 seconds for magnus or
timmy of grabs back the pawn i'm liking
artie's chances here yeah that knight coming
into d3 is nasty yeah and artemia artemyev
coming with and magnus sacrifices his rook in an
attempt to create complete chaos on the board uh
artemia responds with a rook sacrifice of
his own artemia currently up by a knight
uh in exchange for a pawn uh danny resizing
the board at the right moment yet again
and uh but it seems like artemyev
it gets a hold of that white pawn
that was one square away from uh becoming a
new queen and once that pawn is removed from
the board it does seem like this is our tamiya's
moment his sacrifice in the opening about to pay
off as his knight moves to the edge of the
board to eliminate the last pawn from magnus
and he goes after the pawn
magnus tries to give a check
artemyev gets the king away wow magnus is
fighting yeah he is he's making it tricky
wow what is going on here i have no
idea i mean i should be winning but
classic madness only two seconds with
a knight yeah winning with a knight
against lots of pawns is a very difficult
task right because the knight is such
and he's going to kick the king back with h4 at
some point look at him just sitting tight here
making artemia figure it out with with only the
increment really on the clock oh and our teammate
is going to play h4 no oh what a nice idea by the
way look at the night a unicorn if you if you will
yeah everything what about oh and magnus magnus
is upset he didn't have this idea brilliant play
from artemia absolutely managed to get his knight
in a defensive position magnus is furious with
himself let's bring up the analysis board again
and magnus is furious artemia brings this thing
back to within a game and really the maneuver that
was uh that took this game everyone was remember
how much how much artemia was struggling as
long as this knight was trying to guard the a
pawn so instead artemia realizes the knight is
best over here where it can hold these squares
preventing the king from coming in this is super
instructive seriously the the knight eventually
figures out that e6 is the square for the future
and this frees up the black king to go be the guy
who bullies the pawn just an absolutely brilliant
technique magnus unable to break the blockade
missing this idea of captures and h4 and it's
over because you don't have time to go after
the h pawn with knight g5 guarding protecting and
uh and magnus is busted so okay back to the live
game hammer just wanted to show that that was such
such great technique there from artemyev yeah and
the crucial difference between the knight and the
king as the responsible of stopping magnus's pawn
is that the knight cannot attack the pawn and
prevent it from moving further forward at the
same time whereas the king is able to both attack
and stop the white and the the pond's progress
at the same time so i tamiya they're really
appreciating what uh the pieces are able to do
uh and um and and got his got them
coordinated in the right uh in the right way
yeah well uh yeah a an end game technique
display not from magnus but from his opponent
that hasn't happened a lot today but right there
vladislav brings this thing to within a game
um although as you highlighted earlier hammer
magnus doesn't like losing two in a row
and i do like his position early on here as black
uh yeah uh but i also want to point out the the
amazing thing about these online events uh with
magnus and hikaru being the clearly the top two
players uh in that um in that format uh they are
so expressive and magnus is still shaking his head
over that last game he did not like losing there
and um these emotions we're seeing now from magnus
that's thanks to the camera thanks to the fact
that magnus feels like there's no one around and
he feels like there's no one watching but that's
not the case at all though is it danny no it's
not there's a lot of people watching and as i
like to say when it's online it's there forever
right the internet um and uh yeah so you gotta
you gotta when you make it when you get a clip
of these guys it really is great though jokes
aside because you see you know the emotions the
fighting spirit right chess hasn't always been
known for that but uh i think the online format
and the up close and personal views we get of
the players has kind of brought that to life so
um all right magnus shaking his head he needs
to move on and focus on this one artemia has
kind of equalized now he was a little bit worse
what's going on now um it's a tricky
position chances for both sides
uh what magnus has done well in this game is
that he he's up on time and time management has
been a problem for him throughout this match
um but funny humor we've i was gonna say that
notice that he's am i right do you remember it
correctly like i remember like i do which is
i feel like every time magnus is lost the
next game he ends up being way up on time
yeah he's got some of that that anger
frustration manifesting itself into just a
quick play in the next one and frankly
magnus playing quickly trusting his instincts
that's just as dangerous of an opponent as magnus
questioning his decisions and using a lot of time
knight d5 i thought would be followed by
bishop to f6 we'll see if magnus goes for
that to challenge the diagonal here rook
to c1 maybe threatens knight c6 so you
gotta watch out no magnus says i'm good
on that i'll play bishop of six anyway
yeah good job by magnus getting his bishop
uh to counter uh our tamiya's bishop
and we got a big big tactics here rook
c6 rook c6 bishop b2 knight b2 knight e5
am i right about that for the batcave yeah i
think i was right for once in my life we found it
brilliant and this is what we were talking
about magnus magnus's ability to strike back
in uh when in trouble and he finds the crucial
tactic there the knight attacking both the rogue
and the queen uh and as a result of that artemyev
needed to get his queen out of the way instead of
recapturing magnus's bishop which will now be
a commanding force on the board and we said
for our tamiya to win this for our temiev to uh to
unsettle magnus he needs to win two games in a row
and vladislav has won quite a few games today and
he's had chances to win more but every time magnus
loses a game he strikes back with a vengeance
and that two-point lead or winning two in a row
for our tamiya has just never been there because
magnus always shuts down um uh the opponent's
chances after a loss and how he manages to do that
i would love to know well also look at how he's
managing to do it hammer on the clock as well like
we were saying every time our champion has won
magnus has i don't want to say one dominantly but
kind of right he's come back and one dominantly
he's fixed his time management issues and then
you say to yourself if you're a magnus fan where
is that all along right play faster magnus right
play angry and it feels like magnus is playing
his best chess after losing um and that's
not something he wants to continue to repeat
uh but but as you said it also makes it really
hard for our timber to ever win two in a row
and uh two knights and a pawn in exchange for a
rook that's a dominating advantage and frankly
i'm not sure whether artemyev should resign here
or not from a match strategy standpoint because
if artemyev gets into the one-minute portion
with just a two-point deficit he's definitely
capable of making that up so if he needs to
just take his time uh to to kind of settle
his nerves and and recharge for the next one
then then he should do that that being said
artemis now causing some troubles uh he managed
to capture one of magnus's uh pawns uh and it's
infamous that two knights are uh notorious no no
notorious who is notorious b.i.g uh look at the
fork they're bad at coordinating but let's
show that on the analysis board real quick
biggie biggie strikes again biggie biggie
biggie oh can't you see sometimes the fork
it hypnotizes me look at this knight to c3 you
can't take b2 because of knight to d3 check
that was why the game ended so quickly everyone
artemia was trying to hold with the rook
but no nice c3 punishes the move king f2 and after
the move king e3 you get the queen so there you go
um i had to give you credit for that unintentional
notorious big reference by the way tupac lives
that's a whole nother story
no too american for you
no that's fine danny you you already contributed
with some russian grammar okay so i i got i got a
couple of free cards in your book what about this
line here in this vegeta cough it's the o'kelly
okay according to uh the eco but who believes
just.com's eco right let's talk about the
structure real quick because it's especially
cough structure even though a weirdo kelly with a6
what are your thoughts on on the position we have
here i'm not so so i'm more interested in the time
than the position because magnus has been bad
at uh his time management in the initial hour or
so of the five segment but then he he showed his
true self in towards the end of the time segment
and i feel like we have a repeat going on right
here with magnus now suddenly uh up on time in
two games in a row he's putting pressure on the
opponent he's playing confidently he's playing
quickly he's posing uh problems um it's just
a different version of magnus that seems to
uh to to come out towards the end of each uh
time control right and part of that i think
is just adapting to playing uh first five-minute
chess then adapting to playing three-minute chess
uh magnus has fully adapted he has the
pace now for uh for creating maximum damage
in three-minute chess and he's about to steamroll
our tamiya with his uh bishop and queen and rook
all pointing down uh towards that black king
yeah well said and again it's just all about what
hammer's highlighting is magnus kind of finding
himself toward the end of the time controls also
finding himself getting a little angry whenever
he loses it's like you kind of have to poke the
bear to get the best of the bear um i was just
about to highlight maybe our tim if should have
considered queen g5 to try to get the ladies off
the board instead of bishop five but magnus plays
f4 and no longer is there an opportunity to
exchange the queen so uh this attack could get
ugly and look at the clock it's your the script is
flipped right suddenly magnus loses he's not happy
and here comes the here comes the thunder and
artemia must be regretting those two big chances
he had yeah with the first two games we played
a three minute chess magnus's time management
was all over the place he was playing three
minute games as if they were five minute games
and artemiev had two big chances there to get a
win somehow magnus managed to survive those games
he got a draw out of it and now his mind is fully
adjusted to this three-minute section so much so
that he's finding all the right moves look at that
move i should have gone dr evil pinky finger cuz
man he's like you can have my bishop and
your mojo and i'll get your baby look at that
d4 magnus just removing as many pawns in front of
black's king as he possibly can including not cat
recapturing that bishop because he loved it he saw
that the bishop wasn't going anywhere that that
piece was going to be a problem for artemyev
and this has been magnus's most dominating
performance in this match he just annihilated
artemyev both on the board and on the clock
that's more of a desperate move although
obviously with kings on different sides
of the board everyone you applaud attempts to
open up lines and create attacking chances but
at this point it's sort of desperate because
of how bad the position is queen g3 threatens
e5 and rook f6 watch out here we go he plays
it shake and bake something something's coming
down on the f file it's gonna hurt right um
yeah even great great play from magnus there's
no way that king is surviving with
the brook comfortably finding shelter
deep inside black's position behind the black
pawns and now also being reinforced by its buddy
down on the first rank i'm not sure how uh
but these rooks are are going to be the end
of our time look at that movement d6 with tempo
and here comes c5 next just connecting the passers
so artemia gets desperate by the way
don't blunder it if you take c7 queen e4
wins because of the venus flytrap we'll show
that on the analysis board in just a second
uh now let's show it right now what
else we got to do d take c7 queen e4
and bob's your uncle over here never blunder
the venus flytrap kids you heard here first
okay but of course magnus defends the knight
instead and he's back to completely winning
yeah because now he's going to remove
the last pawn defending black's king
the king is defenseless artemyev resigns it's
uh that was a a second in a row for magnus and
if he keeps up this pace he will have left our
tamiya in the rear view mirror uh well before the
one minute time section so artemyev now not only
having to face a bad trend uh in the match he also
desperately needs to start winning uh because
right now the match is slipping away from him
yeah and this is the biggest whoa g4 this is the
biggest lead of the day if you're just tuning in
uh vladimir bartimi was actually the first to win
today uh in the beginning of the 5-1 segment so
um and it's been some great chess from the russian
but but magnus doing what magnus does as the chat
says angry magnus op right we need like an angry
magnus um hulk oh wait i got one of those he's not
quite angry but you know i keep something i keep
him anytime i think i'm doing something good at
chess.com i just take a look at this face staring
at me over there in my room and then i know
i'm not i'll be here all week don't
forget to tip your waitress okay
um back to this position what's going on
i have no idea i i have especially no idea
after that move from magnus if i'm out of
now i'm exchanging my bishop for the night
yeah uh oh but then magnus exchanges there's
trickiness going on right now oh no he did i
thought he might take with the pawn and just leave
this just what a weird bleeping setup over here
is this like this makes you wonder if there was
like a mouse slip or something right when you look
at the position you go how did the pawn get on g4
like yeah but at the same time it's very creative
play from our yeah and it's clear that he wants
to take magnus into the forest and and have a
little uh talk with him and then see if they both
return unscathed um it's typical play especially
against someone who's shown poor time management
uh to put them in a situation where they need to
think for themselves and cannot rely on um opening
moves that they know in advance now normally this
is the strategy magnus uses against everyone else
but artemyev is using the strategy against magnus
himself and then we'll see if that works out or
if that was uh simply a bad decision on his part
no but also from a practical point of view i
agree with you that artemia you know he he's
losing in the match right but he refuses to go
quietly into the night he's like well if i'm
gonna lose like you said let's drag magnus into
the deep dark forest where where no one knows
what's going on and uh and see if see if i can get
myself back in the in the match as we see though
and as you highlighted magnus is probably the best
in the world at taking people into obscure roads
right and uh he seems to be handling this
g4 approach from our timber just fine
yeah he's going on the offense huh
yeah a5 what's he going to do you know he's going
to do you're going to play king b7 he's going to
put a rook on a8 you're going to play a4 he's
gonna open the a file gonna drop the queen like
it's hot he's gonna do dirty things over here
magnus found his mojo there's no doubting it
right now a4 uh coming in and if that pawn is
captured magnus is going to bring the knight
to b6 and uh it's going to be a disaster the e4
play b7 first which was the move i suggested i
like it just a little more just now you have all
the options you have a4 you have rook a8 coming
you can slow jam it jamie fox style
with rook a8 and knight b6 to prepare
a4 or you can go all in with a4 right away but
i agree with what you said magnus's mojo is back
our timmy was in trouble yeah and artemia now
voluntarily opening up the position around his own
king but he feels like he has to do it in order to
kind of get his pieces uh into defensive positions
around his own king and magnus can now win upon
by capturing uh the the white pawn giving a check
after which magnus is well artemia is forced to
take with his rook and then magnus can use his
pawn to attack that vrook and and force
it uh away um and it seems like magnus
is going for this variation and i think
artemia now going to sacrifice his rook
for magnus's knight which is not what you want to
do when you're down by three games in this format
uh but maybe it's something you were forced to
do yeah i thought he would do it too but instead
he's going to give up the pawn with check maybe he
says after you take it i've actually got kind of a
solid defensive setup finally i am going to bring
the other rook to d1 and double on the d file well
moving over to the other side saying that
well i can try to attack your king as well
however this has caused uh our tamiya a pawn oh
but look at the time magnus is down to 30 seconds
and his king is exposed uh this is the kind of
situation where magnus is going to be very tilted
if he loses this yeah on account of having such
a good position uh previously so if artemyev can
turn this around that would be a huge boost for
him but also uh really um stopped that momentum
uh magnus had had going i think f6 just walked
into knight takes e5 hammer call me crazy just
don't call me shirley i think magnus had knight
e1 by the way maybe crazy move that would have
used those doubled rooks yeah 95 what what's going
on here i don't think magnus saw that you see
the reaction he looks in it is 19 seconds on the
clock we got scrambled eggs here people buckle up
yeah which is hilarious um but yeah he lost
control of this game and now artemia providing
the punishment magnus is down a queen
there's rook d1 you have to play brook c1
yeah this this fell apart artemia doing
a magnus carlson saving something from
nothing and if he wins this game we will
still have a match ladies and gentlemen
our timmy i'm not going quietly into the night
queen up the board putting pressure on black's
knight magnus will have to defend with his king
and then the queen infiltrates behind this coming
uh the pieces kind of a creative defense there
i know the eval bar gets better for white but
i kind of like the awkward up never mind a5
is falling i don't like the awkward blockade
uh well i think artemis is just going to move
his way into the rook's path by the way queen
a5 put a blunder 93 check with a draw which was
crazy so artemyev sees that and gets the king
out of danger what a brilliant heads up play with
four seconds on the clock yeah but it's still not
over magnus's brook is still able to put some
uh pressure on white's king although there the
white queen doing its job one second picking up
pawns on the other side of the board oh my gosh
what is going on here is magnus gonna hold this
five seconds on the clock g5 what a move check
and pawn jack and queen check and queen yeah but
magnus is still fighting because he has a fight
not easy with only three seconds well our tenure
should take that pawn yeah and he does so oh
but now the queen comes in a blockading
position and magnus's knight is too far
away to put pressure on the queen but
magnus coming with the second seat
what just happened what a save the
night the night up against the queen
and the knight you're gonna win he's gonna hurry
seven oh my god he's got the skewer if you take
how did he do that 97 yeah and magnus
gets the fork magnus gets the win
how on earth did he get the win he had a night
against the queen and the knight wins the game
okay have you seen anything like that before
bring back the analysis board and bring
back the funk look at this
position fights up a queen
but it was right here king f5 c4 and i think
you had to play king e4 you had to stop
the move c3 but apparently even king f5 was
no good i guess i guess already the position
is closer than you would like but it's it's really
hard for white to deal with the coming c pawn here
king f5 c4 kudos to magnus for not giving up
but king e4 was the way to hold the advantage
because if check everyone you go here and you
can't play c3 because the knight so when when
artemyev doesn't play king e4 all of a sudden the
eva bar says no longer a win in fact it's a draw
but he didn't even get the draw
he didn't even get the draw
you should have played queen takes
b2 baby i don't even know but all i
know is magnus just won with a knight
versus a queen and item nine exists
magnus definitely finding his mojo in these last
moments of the three three-minute portion he won
two in a row got himself into trouble but works
his magic and goes from a losing position to a
winning position in the time scramble we said
it before the match started the time scramble
is what gave magnus uh the win against maksudu in
the previous matchup and it's what uh once again
it's what gives him the the advantage in this
matchup with artemyev he's just so resourceful and
he's so tricky you cannot even when you're up a
queen you cannot be confident that you're going
to win the game and apparently you can't even
be confident i hate those words coming out of
your mouth right there i hate those words you said
even when you're up a queen you can't be confident
you're going to win the game against magnus you're
so right it stings i was dude i'm still just like
seriously i mean i every time i think i'm
about to pass out under these lights something
crazy happens to wake me up i that that was an
incredible game that was devastating and i think
with it are tamiya imagine how he feels
how do you keep your confidence up how do you
avoid a tilt after losing a game like that and in
addition that was his third loss in a row um he's
devastated right now and if he manages to even uh
cut the gap yeah that would be impressive at this
point because i think magnus now he's got uh three
wins in a row he's confident he's playing quickly
and he's just throwing everything at black's king
artemyev is trying to return the favor with
his pawns but the crucial difference is that
when magnus pushes his pawn further forward he
will attack two pieces at once he will attack
both the black pawn on a6 and he will attack the
black knight forcing there to be some kind of uh
a confrontation uh meaning that magnus is gonna
get rid of his uh b-pawn uh which will open up
uh all of uh of the files he needs
to put pressure on artemis king
well i yeah i was giving magnus credit for time
management but right now i think he should just
go for it yeah he's maybe overthinking it a little
bit he is better but may not matter if you if you
reach a time scramble with a with a full minute
disadvantage um by the way it's it's possible
this ends up being our last three minute game
everyone so a shout out to subscribe before we
hit the break uh those of you who enjoy ads will
will love um the latest edition of capital one
bringing you a new lobby where you can uh i don't
know i'm not gonna do a capital one thing they
don't sponsor the show but others will watch me
and you hammer throw down like a couple of tools
in uh in the prime time smackdown all right
95 was played it's funny because you take a
bunch of time a minute and 21 seconds to be
exact and you don't even play a good move
with the move 95 and it's funny because we've
seen this happen several times when magnus loses
magnus angry magnus played better um now he's not
playing playing too great in this game while he's
trying to go into an end game and frankly that
has brought him the results previously in this
matchup but he spent a lot of time uh thinking uh
before he reached this decision um i think he's
doing just fine and i think artemiev i should
try to put a speed on because uh he he doesn't
want to get into another time scramble against
magnus we've seen what magnus is capable of
in those situations i can't get over the knight
over the queen all right we'll have to ask them
about that game afterwards king v8 is a very good
move bar temiev he wants to use the c8 square to
put pressure on the weak and backwards c3 pawn
uh notice that he doesn't doesn't trade on d4 and
help fix magnus's structure now magnus is trying
to force him to do so so our tv says no i will not
wow what a creative move by me we bring the
analysis board up real quick the point everybody
is trading queens here would create a situation
where the g2 pawn is a serious and backward target
magnus plays this move g3 says will you trade and
fix my pawns artemis says no but now g4 if you
go back to f4 i will trade because i have a pawn
that's protected and no longer backwards sort of
sort of just sneakily fixing the
weaknesses in the structure it's absolutely
i just that was a brilliant positional
idea there from the world champion
i i completely agree uh but on the other
hand it cost him a lot of time on the clock
down to eight seconds uh with so many pieces
still on the board uh artemyev has been having
um a better position several uh games so far but
he's always um wasted them and let magnus get
in at the very last moment is this the one where
our tamiya strikes back keeping the match within
striking distance as we go into the one minute
portion i think the only thing that's clear is
that this is gonna be the last three minute
game there's no way they're gonna manage to
finish within the next 50 seconds as we see on our
countdown clock on the top and that means artemia
really needs to win this game to have within uh
three games going into the one minute portion
agreed town population us um two seconds
for magnus four seconds now for our champion
okay but f2 falls when you take there and
here comes knight d3 check with b4 hanging
wow and should magnus now resign to
get another game in this three minutes
or 15 seconds he's dead lost in the rook
ending magnus is going down here for sure
but three seconds look at the technique from
our tamiya i'm not even going to lose the c
pawn yet brings the king up i love it okay there's
a wall of black pawns going and moving up towards
white's king yeah and those pawns are connected
that means they're standing next to each other
and magnus is working his end game magic hold
the phone uter suddenly says it's equal what's
oh my god magnus why he's around a second end game
in a row and artemyev is gonna get the abortion
on this game because they're they're done
with the three minutes the game has been
aborted uh they're down to one minute chess
with magnus winning ma four games in a row
wasting one brilliant position after another i
thought with the black pawns being able to protect
each other i thought that was going to be it and
he had the opportunity here to move his rook so
that he was attacking both of magnus's pawns at
the same time and that would have ended the game
right there and then but for the second time in
a row the time trouble gets magnus's uh opponent
and the resourcefulness magnus shows and
the pressure it it it illustrates how much
pressure these guys are under uh when
they're under 10 seconds and repeatedly
magnus's opponents makes mistakes artemia should
have sacrificed his rook on this white pawn um
and with unclear consequences uh instead uh
his work kind of got torn between the two
white pawns moving their way up the board
and and magnus secured himself a new queen
as two pawns uh one square away from
queening was just too much to handle for uh
unbelievable again i was trying to move the pieces
as you were talking about the finish there partner
but yeah especially right here was the win really
hard in time pressure but you had to go for both
ben magnus again if you're if you're just joining
us where have you been magnus carlson now of five
games after a tie at one point our timid was
leading it was a close match but magnus carlson
got angry he rattles off several victories
in a row and wins two games back-to-back
from a dead lost position and we're going to
have a break here enjoy wrench versus hammer
prime time smackdown that's me and that guy right
there that guy and we'll be right back for the
one minute segment here and the first of a double
header on this speed chess championship thursday
boom all right let's do oh my god stop playing bad
chess hammer i just i feel like as a countryman to
magnus you should do better you know i i agree
i i would play something more decent if i could
it's just that i i have been destroyed through
years of playing this crappy opening i've just
been dreaming i'm so bad i'm winning now though
i don't even know what to do with you it's so bad
and you're frustrating me right now you are
frustrating me okay position is still horrible
i don't even care oh i shouldn't have done that
almost pre-moved rook takes f2 would have been
somewhat unfortunate a decent amount of pawns i
guess like this isn't the worst amount of pawns
that anyone's ever had no it's not but look how
many pawns you have now yeah crap your style is so
irritating i'm pretty much meaning it's a
horrible style that you have well thank you
these openings that you play you want to know
my secret i thought i was bad at openings god
all right damn put yourself together get the
bishop pair and go into an end game every single
game 100 success right always imagine dan that
they're that they're at home in their underwear
and it makes you feel better always imagine that
makes me feel better don't be embarrassed there's
a little pep talk in myself whenever i feel like
i'm embarrassing myself on camera i just go like
remember people are at home naked cheeto marks
on their bare chest watching you and judging
you that's you know don't be embarrassed that's
what i tell myself i no longer wish for my kids
to have your brain oh no i'm kidding but this is
getting abusive all right here we go all right i'm
gonna be black against the stupid g3 crap you know
what's coming you literally know my first five
i know what's coming do something about
it i hate you i'm gonna do what levy did
i'm gonna play this sort of
like crazy looking sort of uh
crazy looking kind of you know whatever this is
okay step one acquire bishop pair
step one completely what's step two
like still have a bad position even with the
bishop bear preferably not getting checkmated
because that's working out for you yeah
not right now this is this is no no i'm not
i am not doing this with you i'm up a piece
and you're gonna lose this freaking game
or i'm gonna lose my proverbial bleep okay
if i lose this game it's not because i'm a piece
down it's because i don't have the bishop pair
that's the problem yeah that's how
much faith i have in the bishops
you have a problem bro the bishop
hera is not the only thing in life
okay i was okay it was okay it
really really gave me a scare
really gave me a scare meaning you really
gave me a scare hammer and i tried like it
uh can you make that move i am not really
sure kind of scared very scared be very scared
can i i'm not gonna lose to danny on camera please
no just my dude worst things have happened to
better people okay i'm not sure that's entirely
true oh wait i'm good i just do something bad
fine
no i lost connection no way no way no way you lose
is horrible i lost my connection this is
outrageous this is rigged are you kidding me
as much as the next chess player but
that's where the smackdowns are happening
oh come on it just happened to be during a
game against the chief chess officer whatever
my connection just randomly disappeared
when i was about to go right rematch your
connection's fine that was an excuse i
just flagged you like a dirty dirty dog
how'd that how did that loss feel right there
in that prime time i don't want to talk about it
how did that like you were you were in a lost rook
ending and you got flagged ruthlessly
i mean you want to talk about that
all right let's go to the predictions
hammer's silent i uh i know that the
smarter chess stats say that magnus is gonna be
four games better and one plus one twist ending
what if artemia ends up being four games
better oh crap i realize he's still gonna lose
yeah uh it's been uh are you still
just frustrated with yourself um yeah
well um jokes aside this has been an amazing
day and we know that the current scoreboard is
five games to the advantage of magnus carlsen but
it's been um it's been a super close match on the
board in a lot of ways and the world champion
showing why he is uh why he is such and uh
always seems to to have the moves and the critical
moments including winning knight versus queen it's
hard to talk about anything else besides that
game right now and then the rook ending coming up
good yeah magnus winning two losing games in a
row that puts that kind of puts everything to rest
i don't think artemis can can come back from that
had he got the wins the points he deserved the
score would have been eight to seven everything to
play for instead now here he is down five points
uh it just shows how how close this match was and
frankly how much the the current result is is a
complete lie uh compared to what we have witnessed
because it's been a closely contested match
with just mad magnus pulling out his magnus magic
uh at the end uh which has just catapulted his
number of points into a number that he uh he
he doesn't believe vladislav doesn't believe
uh artemia just shaking his head and i'm
still stunned that magnus got away with that
well the 1-1 section should be starting right
now any second it is going to kick off and here
we go a half an hour left for artemyev to uh
to make his move if a historical comeback is in
store for today but you know you said it all you
know the the scoreboard doesn't totally reflect
what an exciting uh day we've had how close
the games have been and the five one portion
the fact that we felt our tim you've might have
been the better player overall you know um but
but again that's why he's as you said magical
magnus and now we've got some weirdness coming
with the double fee and kettles for both sides
sign me up this is going to be an awkward party
well it's very likely that all those bishops are
going to be pointing at each other and frankly
uh they might just all get exchanged off but
it's artemia with a better position because of
magnus having his one knight out on the edge
of the board that gives white a slight edge
yeah agreed it's a double hanging pawn position at
some point the tension's going to break you got to
give white i think the teeny edge i think having
released the uh the eye of the tiger on g2 first
and now yeah now oh he took with
the pawn i wonder if there was an
awkward way to take advantage of the knight but no
and magnus is going to be targeting these
white pawns uh artemyev is going to claim
that these pawns give him a very nice
central control and he's going to try
to get his knights in there artemia
now going to move this knight up to b5
trying to get it into uh d6 getting it right
in there uh annoying magnus to the maxim
speaking of annoying that move knight before
knight c6 got him annoyed artemia because
he doesn't doesn't get much out of it and if the
knights are traded everyone one thing to recognize
with hanging pawns is that as pieces come off the
board the pawns become easier to gang up on all of
a sudden it's sort of turning around and although
okay what are we doing here yeah i'm surprised
artemia went for the exchanges he's down five
points it felt as though he he needed to to keep
more pieces on the board we'll see if he can get
a win here in the time scramble uh in the end game
but frankly don't count on it because magnus
in the end game he doesn't care if he's down
a queen he's just gonna win them that has been
the crucial difference uh so far in this matchup
actually gets away with winning a pawn on the side
of the board are tamiya pawn up in this end game
uh but when he didn't manage to win with a queen
up i can't get excited about him being a pawn up
it's it's hard it's not going to be the punch
line for the day because it's something we've
rarely seen uh in an event featuring you know
two super grand masters even if it is blitz so
our timmy oh but there magnus makes a huge
mistake allowing the knight to get the
double attack on the rook and on the pawn it
means our temiev snatches the pawn and magnus
uh two pawns down that i do not
believe he's going to be able to save
and artemia strikes back is it going to be too
late he's down five points in the matchup uh got
weird weird threats coming here with rookie three
even knight f4 i mean the pawn pawn is hanging
yeah and magnus is familiar with the format
there's no way he's gonna resign when he's up five
in the match here it's all about surviving as long
as possible to keep that match clock ticking yep
26 minutes left remember that is something that
especially pays dividend in a close match but
even just as an insurance policy you're up by
five make your opponent earn it right and um
when you win games down queens hammer it's hard to
ever justify resigning so uh but there are tamiya
before the checkmate he takes the first game of
this one minute portion the lead is down to four
and artemyev for the third or fourth time in this
match gets the opportunity to inflict two losses
in a row for magnus so far he has not succeeded
in doing that uh which i think is the the crucial
thing you need to do to unsettle magnus to get
magnus in a poor psychological state um can
artemyev get the second win or will magnus do what
he's made a habit out of uh which is play somehow
much better after having lost yep it's been the
story of the day our teammate has been close it
seemed at times to getting that magical second
victory will anyone in the scc be able to put
magnus on a tilt um we'll we'll find out of course
i don't i don't know that it's going to happen
today it would take a miracle for our tim you have
to come all the way back but it starts with one
game yeah it starts with one game and then there's
another game and artemyev gets his knight in an
excellent position putting pressure on white's
bishop which means that magnus cannot castle the
big question is what's next i think artemis should
just move his bishop out to d7 and he does do that
magnus's brook is out of squares magnus cannot
castle the rook is is is in trouble every piece is
in trouble it looks as though our tamiya is going
to take a second game in a row here magnus brook
has been trapped the rook has nowhere to go uh but
on the other hand magnus just got his bishops in
good positions i was gonna say everything you
said was true is what i would have commented
too but then also the exchange stack happens and
magnus's pawns are running wild what in the world
his resourcefulness is just it's incredible
it's it's incredible seriously and because
that was such a such a a bad position
for white and certainly artemia blundered
but but neither you or i can exactly say where and
just like that and then i i have no idea what's
going on yeah i think bishop c7 was actually
better than bishop d6 than what magnus played but
either way he's he's back in the game after what
seemed like a dead loss and why is magnus allowing
the knight to be exchanged for the bishop i'm not
sure it feels to me like artemyev in this opposite
colored bishop end game should be able uh to hold
on for a draw um but magnus coming with his rook
magnus has a pawn one square away from becoming
a new queen artemiev is trying to eliminate
all the pawns on the other side of the board
um but now magnus will get his king involved
and there's not really much artemiev can do with
it artemis king is unable to participate in play
uh because of the white rook pointing down making
sure that artemium cannot get his king next to
the white pawn yeah and what surprises me is that
magnus is moving his king in the wrong direction
now you got to watch out that was actually a
really nice trick from our champion it might
force rookie five because the point is if the
bishop moves everyone yeah d7 falls and if he
didn't h5 was a threat so nice defense there
from artemia of forcing the rook exchange now
he should for sure you should for sure hold this
and uh okay well hammer it's not two wins in a row
but it's two decent results in a row a win and a
draw so yeah but he had the upper hand and let it
slip and even though he's happy to have avoided
a loss um i just can't help the feeling that
um artemiev really needed that two in a row uh
to get momentum and look at magnus's reaction
there magnus's reaction was not one of i wasted
an opportunity to win magnus's reaction was
i got away with that right and that three
and a half more minutes off the game clock
match clock right no i'm with you i'm just
saying you know but there's a will there's
a way and right now with 21 minutes left artemyev
uh another victory here would would keep it close
so the point is point is you just i don't know for
sure if i'm right it's been a long day already but
i think magnus has always won after
losing and that was the first time
artemia drew the next game so that's all i
was saying a couple decent results in a row
yeah he i think he desperately needs to win
this one yeah no i agree it's it's time to win
or and now he knows it as well because he's going
aggressive with his pawns pushing magnus's queen
back and now putting his rook on the same file
as magnus's queen the queen gets away how are
you going to break down magnus's position here
i think part of the problem here for artemyev
is that it's going to be a 90 move game magnus is
just going to block off everything and then the
match clock is going to run its course in addition
to it being almost impossible to defeat magnus
in in such a a technical position meaning that
uh there's like uh a very limited of pieces
left um it's just also the fact that magnus can
keep the game going for quite some time exploiting
the fact that the match clock keeps running
yep and i'm liking the way magnus handled the
pressure to be honest regardless of all the other
difficulties we've said artemia faces i think that
it's roughly equal in terms of in terms
of the queen side play and the two-on-one
being the long-term advantage i feel like is uh is
good for magnus although this moved by d5 that's
that's kind of irritating because if you take your
knight is being pushed to a less than ideal square
um and magnus is spending a lot of time figuring
it out uh in the end deciding to retreat um and
both players now uh under 20 seconds so here comes
the two on one as we said uh but now artemia has
successfully blockaded are you gonna put it on
c6 go for a five minutes gonna move it forward
do it but there's knight d7 you gotta watch upward
no queen d3 what a weird move well magnus's queen
attacking both white's rook and white's knight
grabbing a pawn in the process so magnus won
quite a lot of material there but gets forced back
afterwards and now artemyev despite being a pawn
down he has this pawn running up the board trying
to become a new queen magnus up upon um seems to
have enough resources in the position to stop that
white pawn from moving forward but magnus plays
white figured this out somehow i mean that what a
weird position this is one that as a chess fan i
feel robbed i wish they i wish the players had
more time to play that position a little more
accurately because the email bar was nutty and i
think um i don't think the best chess was played
but hey what did we call for we said our timmy
has to win another game in a row and it might
yeah but he's not won this one yet magnus uh as
always being very resourceful creating trouble for
white trying to can't happen again oh
my gosh trying to get he's losing in
what i have no idea what's going on hey f2
shame on you what is going on the eval bar
is is still in magnus's uh in artemia's favor
he barely knows this one pawn he has moving
forward that pawn needs to become a new queen
if he's to have any chance of winning this game
magnus right now just giving checks to the white
king repeatedly and the white king is struggling
to know and now he blundered the pawn which means
magnus now will go for the win uh our temmie of
just having three seconds left this is anyone's
game the knight and queen are the best duo in
the business when it comes to mating nets against
the king and so i i would rather have the queen
and knight here than the queen of rook this is i
agree the night is so tricky and white's king is
poorly defended uh so it's much easier for uh
magnus to hide his king than it is for artemia
yeah and just to prove the point if if
magnus wanted to draw he could offer
the queen straight now he might take it with
perpetual here indeed he does but still that was
it was a game that don't kid yourself magnus
was the one hoping to win it toward the end
and again he prevents artemia from getting that
that so desired second win in a row right it's
it's been a win for artemia and bullet everyone
two draws but not another victory that artemia
needs now with only 16 minutes left and in both
draws it was artemyev who was closest to the wind
and also in the last two games of the five
three minute portion it was artemiev who had
very promising winning positions which he wasted
in time trouble and ended up losing consider
uh danny if all of those four games had gone in
artemis favor instead he would be the clear leader
of this match but now instead he he keeps you
know having to chase a win trying to get back uh
as a result of of not exploiting the chances he's
been getting yep dog chasing his tail going in
circles not getting anywhere that's how our tamiya
feels by the way we have more than 10 000 live
viewers on youtube that might be a record for our
growing youtube channel we've been live streaming
on twitch a little bit longer over the last
10 plus years here on chess.com so that's cool
and uh still got 24 000 of you almost on twitch
so thanks for being here remember right after this
match we'll have interviews with the world
champion magnus carlson vladislav artemyev
and then we buckle up for nakamura fedo sev
uh it's that's gonna be a fun one like hammer
keep saying it's quite a day today what
a day to be alive huh take that 20 20.
two speed chess uh quarterfinals on the same day
and also it being hikaru and magnus uh it's just
perfect uh i think gtx h3 was the move there
and for some reason artemia took magnus's bluff
yeah i think he takes winning for black
yeah well based on the evaluation bar
that was definitely the case but neither player
seemed to believe the attack black had going on
well now magnus is back in the driver's
seat with a dominant knight on e5
and that knight was just shutting down the studio
in regards to any kind of action over there
on the king side so interesting sort of uh
central blockade there from carlson artemia
misses his opportunity oh man and with with only
14 minutes left if this one ends up being a dub
for the world champion i think we'll almost
have to call it our timmy you've got to hold
yeah no doubt and magnus's pawns on the queen side
are terrifying he has two pawns that protect each
other as they move forward and these pawns are
going to become queens our tamiya resigns magnus
has a five point lead and look at the relief in
magnus's face that's how close this match has been
magnus is thrilled to get that five-point lead
which normally would be more than enough to feel
extremely confident that you're gonna win this
but but magnus is like oh wow this has been a
challenge i'm so happy uh i'm about to to win this
no i agree that face says it all if any of you
were late this has been a super close match all
day our timmy have led and felt like the better
player in the first segment magnus seems to have
found it where it matters the most but that that
relief you just saw was magnus kind of feeling
like all right five games lead 12 minutes left
i think i'm gonna get this and he has a ton of
respect for his opponent in vladislav artemyev
and and magnus now uh he's gonna get more points
uh but even if he didn't get more points he would
be able to run the clock uh as it stands on these
last five games feels so close you're right like
this feels like a match that just a second ago
could have gone either way yeah artemia actually
snatches a pawn in the center but magnus with the
two bishops putting pressure on white's position
is saying that even though i'm down a pawn i'm
gonna create some trouble and this guy on the side
of the board that uh danny just highlighted
that is uh instrumental to magnus's plan
because he's gonna push this guy forward and
um white's king is gonna feel uncomfortable
at the at the pressure eleven by the way uh
speaking of uncomfortable look at the clock
yeah no magnus is uh in in the in the mode now
yeah he's in his killer mode and i think he's
about to sacrifice something on white's king
position to really open up the board and create
trouble i wonder if he could have even taken
h2 with g3 and then h3 that would have been a
way to sacrifice something it doesn't
um not necessary but oh wow and now
artemia he's got an attack going on as well
both players attacking the computer massively
favors white and then changes his mind and
massively and now uh saying it's about equal
and now favors white again incredible
stuff there's an open file for a white
rook to point down towards this black king i
think that's going to be the deciding factor
when white gets the rook involved there's just no
saving it and artemia is going to finish with a
nice rook sacrifice rook b8 rook oh he had it rook
b8 and then rook over and queen in i think was
also made but this should work i think it should
be good enough we've said that a couple of times
today danny oh yeah we've said that what we mean
it magnificent exchange and then the checkmate
our tamiya gets another one back and um i mean
i guess technically he can still get a comeback
four games in 10 minutes but he's gonna have to
play faster he's gonna spend need to spend no time
on his clock while putting the squeeze on magnus
yeah it's not it's not going to be easy it it's
possible if not um improbable right i mean the
the 10 minute time is just it goes by faster
than you think right especially with increment you
feel like no four games in 10 minutes like that's
doable but you know um really really hard although
again you watched the ferruccia fedo save match
that i comment commentated on with the it was
incredible that was incredible and it was it was
four minutes and a two-game deficit but it took it
took not just winning but then starting the last
game as time expired and that's the rules of the
match format if a game starts it does count and
then winning that so even there yes it happened
but it barely got in under the wire so um yeah
and uh opposite side castling is definitely what
artemyev likes to see when he's chasing uh a lead
uh the problem uh being that magnus is creating
some trouble for black's king i guess that's just
the cost of doing business artemiev is happy to
get his pawns involved he's to be putting pressure
on magnus's bishop and i think there's a very
real possibility now that artemyev is going to win
this game i think he has a great attack going on
towards magnus's king yeah magnus taking his time
to figure it out because a4 is a problem if you
play c3 everyone the point is a4 comes with tempo
and then a3 to follow would undermine the b pawn
between c3 so that's why magnus doesn't play c3
but now he may not have any choice
right i mean a4 is coming like it or not
well matt you gotta make a4 himself i thought
because now oh this is tricky magnus is trying
to shut down everything if art artemia
plays b4 then a4 from magnus and vice versa
uh artemiev needs to try and open up the
situation get rid of those pawns so that he can
get in towards white's king and the way he does
it is very instructive or tamiya having give
given up two pawns is still the favorite to
win this game because of white's exposed king
and now it's just a matter of getting
more pieces involved in the attack
maybe knight h5 is a move brook creates a move
yeah i would go with the rook and i wouldn't
spend this much time yeah our tennis needs to keep
the the time situation within reach yeah rook c3
grace if you take 94 was a fork town and now queen
takes the pawn yes and then you take very nice
he gets back the two pawns he sacrificed
initially and now still has an attack
going while white's bishop on b1 is a horrible
nobody just hung his knight just straight up
yeah he misses it and magnus
missed it bishop c won
is taking the bishop and now magnus sees the
knight in the center uh once again an end game
both players very low on time but artemia about
to bring his king into the fold i think black's
king is going to decide this end game or tim yam
strikes twice in a row for the first don't don't
i don't wanna i'm like hold your horses over there
partner given what we've seen i'm not gonna call a
victory at this point i mean our tim you've hung
his knight magnus missed it our timmy of hangs is
i mean magnus hangs his bishop instead oh yeah i'm
calling it danny artery is gonna win two in a row
but i think it's too late for him i think okay
now okay now he can play kinky five in here so
yeah yeah but now there's pressure against
these black puns i didn't really like that
trade from yeah but he's got he's six he should
be okay right yeah you take advantage of the pin
should still win yeah okay good play never magnus
is gonna play this trust a russian in an end game
instructor russian and end games that sounds
like uh well like the next netflix series
but despite all of this excitement despite
artemyev about to win his second game in a row
he's not able to catch up because the match clock
is running out he needs to have three wins uh
in in the rest of this match and i'm not sure
five minutes is enough to get those three wins
he's not only gonna have to play quickly
and amazingly in the next couple of games
he also needs to stop using his own clock the
only way artemium can mount to come back here
is if he in his next game plays as if it's like
a 10 second game right he needs to avoid spending
his own time because at this point spending
his own time will run down the match clock
yep and i think magnus i should like he said too
little too late not enough time um but uh that
was still a very a very impressive victory and
carlson just ensuring ensuring that every second
will go off the clock shows you how much respect
he has for his opponent doesn't want to allow
any opening cynical but it's so great this is what
this format is all about let the clock run out
you lost control of the match your opponent has
won two games in a row you need to stall to uh
to get rid of that momentum well magnus laughing
a little bit kind of like sorry man but hey this
is this is them is the rules them's the rules
he's like don't hate the player hate the game
that was that magnus laugh right there let's
let's clip it magnus don't hate the player
hate the game man where is the next game are
10 i don't know both sides trying to rematch
i'm sure they're not delaying but it happens
sometimes um yeah wow a great game from artemyev
as you said not going to be enough time and uh i
think the clock was 425 so i'm guessing we'll add
some total time back on the clock just for good
measure um i'm not sure exactly what's going on
we'll check in with them
but this break is uh definitely in magnus's favor
uh because he gets some time to calm himself down
and um and uh and on the heels of those two
defeats in a row you can see it's taken a toll on
magnus he really doesn't like uh losing two in a
row he lost momentum in the match and now artemyev
needs to play super quickly uh to have any chance
of uh of getting back his uh three-point deficit
yeah three points
and uh it get he gets a good start here artemyev
um uh with his pieces developed magnus opting for
not castling and allowing an attack to be mounted
on the black king very dangerous play here from
magnus um with the king still in the center with
an artemia desperate to get a win can he do three
in a row against the world champion that would be
the task right unfortunately with time although
let's not let's not forget everyone of the format
right every game is actually worth probably a
couple hundred bucks at this point because the
prize money while 3 000 goes to the winner the
remaining 3000 is split by win percentage and so
uh everyone goes home with cash and even if you
lose there's an opportunity to still fight down
the stretch so or reason to fight down the stretch
and artemyev going for it with a peace sacrifice
the computer hates it but black's king has been um
undressed the the the pawns no longer there
to defend the king fortunately for magnus
uh there's so many black pieces around and
he's just gonna play his pieces uh to kind of
do the job that the pawns are no longer
there to do uh trying to protect his majesty
i like the threat of f5 here i like the sack right
whether it works or not like you said artemia's
going for it in our final couple games here we're
adjusting the clock to make sure that the time is
accurate based on how much was delayed don't you
stress chad don't worry i'll feed you baby birds
the uh the clock what had time added back to it
but it now reflects the accurate time remaining um
and uh artemia striking with the bishop he magnus
couldn't capture the white bishop because of the
the rook in trouble uh in the corner of the board
but magnus is resourceful and has nine oh my gosh
itself let's bring up the analysis board as the
next game start just a show because what what a
turnaround right bishop takes f7 right winning
tactic for white you know deflect the queen not
so fast magnet says winning tactic for black
you take my queen i take yours with check and
then regain the bishop um yeah and with that win
there's no doubt who's gonna win this match magnus
carlsen is victorious he's going to go into the
semi-finals against maxim barcelo lagrave um but
uh this has been such a close match yeah and uh
with better um nerves and better decision making
in in time scrambles uh our tamiya could have won
this uh match in in a blowout it's been incredible
to watch how magnus manages to create trouble for
his opponent and and get so many points in these
time scrambles even situations where he's losing
he manages to turn it around and even get a win uh
so um in the end magnus wins as we are accustomed
to but um a big fight from the the russian player
yep
well uh this will be the final game uh though
the result of course does count and uh it will
affect prize money and all that stuff but we're
gonna have interviews with the players we'll
get magnus's thoughts on how the match went
facing maxine bache the grav in the next round
and maybe some other things along with it so don't
go anywhere and of course uh hammer and i will do
a quick preview of nakamura fedocea before my
partner steps out and makes way for a new one
a new partner in robert hess um i'm a little
promiscuous today i'm swapping partners around
and uh hammer i know you'll be sitting
there watching hanging out with us in spirit
uh anyway what a day this has been this has been
quite the match this has been a lot closer than
the final scoreboard says it felt like we could
have almost had overtime today your right hammer
might have even been a victory for our champion
if he could have converted some of those time
scrambles but i i guess it's no accident because
this is the same thing we were talking about in
magnus's last match he somehow ends up landing on
his feet he somehow has the margins in his favor
and uh artemia they're getting a double
attack on white's bishop and on the
white king or tamiya gets the extra piece it
looks as though he's going to win this last
game of the day but it's only going to be a
consolation prize uh because the final score
if artemium now brings home the bacon uh it is
going to be 13 for magnus and 10 for artemyev
so not the uh definitely not the prediction that
smarter chess went for and you know we we like to
make fun of the of the module it's it's right a
lot of the time but i do not like that decision
from our tamiya he gives and that just gave
the draw right back yeah he gives up the knight
he had extra and now magnus is just trying to
get rid of as many pawns as he can uh secure
yeah and magnus able to now put up a blockade
on the dark squares the disadvantage of having
only one bishop the reason you need to have the
bishop pair is because they need to work together
one controlling the light squares the other
controlling the dark squares here magnus has been
able to put his uh king his knight and his pawn
on the dark squares there's no way for artemyev to
make progress and this last game was pretty much
descriptive of this entire day artemia playing
great chess getting advantages but magnus staying
in there showing his fighting spirit and and
managing to to get points in a lot of difficult
situations agreed agreed agreed and it wouldn't be
a show with john love the camera if we didn't end
with a reference to why you need the bishop here
okay hopefully you enjoyed that just like all
of our subscribers will enjoy the last of our
prime time smackdown between me and hammered
that took place a couple weeks ago a lot of fun
hopefully everyone is enjoying that content don't
go anywhere when we return we have interviews
with magnus carlson vladislav artemyev before
previewing nakamura fedo sayo we'll be right back
you can't see what's going
on on my screen that was the
server intervened on your behalf oh wait are
you are you literally disconnected okay cool
connection for one second but in one minute
chess that's all it takes oh my god it didn't
matter hammer i was crushing you up two pawns in
a rook end game and flagging you like in a like
like a i don't even know what i want
to say because it's not appropriate
i don't want to hear it you know what you want
to say but you've decided it's not appropriate
i think it's like wait am i going to get my own
night trap yeah well ghana or already damn how did
that happen how did that happen all right my moves
are just comebacks are possible miracles happen
come on come on let's do this there you go
there you go make bad moves hammer that's
what i love about you always up to make a bad
move for a friend oh you are you are just an
adorable little bad move maker by the way how's
that rook feel over there it's fine don't worry
about it does that rook feel okay how's that
it's fine don't worry about it oh you did get
out of it somehow i'm actually really irritated
about that uh come on this is so awkward for you
you see everything is fine crap
everything was not fine for you and you
know it i wasn't even concerned for a second
oh man i'm going one time again
how did that happen i hope
honestly somewhat uncomfortable
situation going down
what are you doing stop attacking things
what no way you just did that oh my god
you're such a dirty player i love it no
no i'm in check oh it was a check with the fish
i almost i almost rocked your world like
the little norwegian country girl you
truly are honestly i'm surprised the server
didn't come in and take my connection again
everybody blames chess.com servers when they
lose to me it's part of life you know but
you know i i thought you were
better than that i guess i was wrong
and welcome back everyone we are now joined by
our players world champion magnus carlson and
vladislav artemyev guys first of all thank
you both this was uh quite the show today a
super exciting match and vlad we'll start
with you i i know the scoreboard reflects
a four-point loss it felt a lot closer
than that felt like you were playing
super well throughout the day what can you say
about those time scrambles where magnus just
continues to create resourceful problems and how
he how he how he stole some victories there from
you in those uh especially in that three minute
portion with the knight versus queen ending
uh yes i think that much was very interesting
and uncompromising but also i can say that
i i have big problems when i have last seconds
and probably i missed some great chances
but okay it fight and i it's only my problems
so thank you magnus and congratulations
uh yes maybe i lost crazy two games when
i was queen against rook and tonight
it was very terrible for me and more crazy i think
it was rooks and game with two pawns for me yes i
i was very disappointed after this and it's really
difficult play after such crazy games but i try to
make some fight and okay no normal match not good
result but my opponent was very strong so okay
um magnus back back over to you then uh one of the
things that hammer and i observed today is that
every time you lost a game it felt like it felt
like the beast came out people were saying in chat
like angry magnus is overpowering and was there
something for you that if you had a tough game
it kind of riled you one of the things we noticed
is you played faster the next game and you tend to
to really find your form is is that something you
can talk about as far as when you lose a game what
it kind of you know woke you up a little bit and
made you feel even more focused for the next game
uh i have to say that uh the match overall was uh
was tough um almost every game was was tough like
i think over the course of the match there was
one game which i uh which i won without any any
hiccups so if you're talking about angry
that was sort of my constant constant mood
throughout the match like every game was was long
it felt like i was outplayed in almost every game
and so it was just uh it was just a massive
struggle uh and i played i played vlad before so
i knew that he uh he's very strong and i knew
that the match was never going to um to be uh
be easy but still like when you're when you're
there i think we both really really felt the
the tension very much in in that sense it was
a very interesting and and um yeah very open
match as well um magnus um what is the ability
you have to turn around uh difficult situations
i don't know keep making moves and uh sometimes
i escape sometimes uh sometimes i don't um
i mean i've had experience
in this format as well like
i played um overall in this format so
many games with grishok for instance and
yeah he just outplays me every time a bit like
vlad does so i have a lot of experience in
trying to fight back and be as resource
resourceful as possible i think it's
just knowing when to start playing fast helps and
also to be on constant lookout for for tricks i
don't think there's any you said you have a
lot of experience in this format magnus and
and talking about that toward the end of
this match here you were definitely using
the time to your advantage right and was
that just kind of a you know the show of
respect you have for vladislav you wanted to
make sure that with the lead you protected it
kind of letting the time kick off the clock
there in the final games of the bullet portion
no as i said before even though i
was leading by quite a big score um
there was no moment in the match where i
felt like i'm taking over he's starting to um
to crack it always felt like the games were
um very balanced in the sense that we both
both had chances and never felt like i was sort
of breaking away and in that sense i thought i
have to be um i have to be careful because i
didn't really feel that i could control the match
very much and in that sense it was good just to to
to let it run out i was very mindful of that who
knows if the match had gone on for another another
half an hour it could could have ended differently
yep makes sense magnus uh with the the jokes aside
we were saying about how we observed you getting
frustrated being angry hammer and i talked a lot
about how great this year has been with so many
awesome online events you have the magnus carlson
tour that you've been doing at chess24 which is
incredible we have these events where we get to
see the players on camera talk a little bit if you
will as the ambassador for the game that you are
what you feel online chess has done right giving
it sometimes feel like fans feel a little more
intimately close to you guys in online events
right because we get the camera we get to see
magnus at home kind of reacting emotionally
in ways that you don't always over the board
so if you would say how you feel about the
online events here and how great it's been
for fans to be able to connect with players
on camera like this yeah i think you hit on
on the the biggest point right there that you
i mean somewhat paradoxically you feel you
feel like you get more raw emotions when people
are on um are online than they are
irl so um yeah that's that's certainly
certainly the case and for us as well it's
it's it's good to play from uh from home and um
yeah it's just uh it's just a great thing
for for chess i think that there are now
very serious online online events
that people people can can watch
for sure well and we appreciate that and
all the events that are running online both
with chess24 and just.com and we think they've
been amazing so vladislav i want to just say
again i know that the score obviously not
what you wanted to win the match but what
do you take away from something like this as far
as what you learn despite you know you played the
world champion that's one thing you learned
and he plays a lot of good moves but what do
you learn as far as things you can take away
and improve upon in future speed chess matches
uh yes before the match i have opinion that magnus
is favorite of course but i'm also not bad player
so i wanted to found my chances and of course
i not can say that i am happy now because
uh when when you lost it's always bad but still
i not can say that i was very bad i was normal i
think maybe i can play better i i think that i can
play a little better yes but it's a difficult walk
one such long match against
magnus so i must walk more and
i will wait others great events and hope that
uh iridone in speeches championship in next year
thank you yeah well thank you and best of luck
at the russian super final we know you'll be
traveling to that and you've had you had an
incredible year you're someone who qualified
in the speeches grand prix you've been one of the
most consistent albeit dominant forces in the in
the world of online chess so uh you earned it and
great match today uh magnus last question for you
you've got mvl in the semifinals
thoughts on thoughts on that match-up and
uh how do you think you pair off again uh
face-off against the fresh the frenchman
uh i think he's a very different uh different
player than vladislav in this um format like
maxim is a lot more reliant on on tactics and
and and speed so it's certainly going to be very
very different very very different experience
yeah well best of luck in the next round magnus
we'll see you next weekend um vladislav good luck
at the russian super final and uh thank you both
for your time uh thanks a lot see you in next time